We are back
live. Hi. I ended up getting like I
don't even know how many meetings
today. So, here's the
plan. Pull reream up on another window
here. I'm going to write some
docs. It's going to be very
exciting. And uh that is currently the
plan. I do not like writing docs. It
drives me nuts. I really just want this
release to be done so I can get back to
doing uh cool science and
engineering.
So, I'm just going to be here doing this
for the next hour and a half and then
I'll be back in the
morning. Goal is to make docs as good as
possible in the absolute minimum
possible amount of
time. Stream view. There we go.
Okay, here's the current
page. I think it's like decent. At least
people have told me it's not.
Um, I don't even know if people think
that the docs aren't decent or that
Puffer Lib isn't easier to use or like
Puffer Lib isn't easy enough to
use because those two could be the same
problem, right?
Let me take a quick look at this and
then we will start uh we'll start
writing
them. Okay. Paragraph of
text. Does this do anything? Puffer li
is a library for sane and simple
reinforcement learning. Our key features
are clean puffer. Our turb training demo
is a turbocharged version of clean RL's
PO plus LSTM. Several fold performance
improvements and major quality of life
upgrades. Train at 1 mill plus steps per
second and easily run hyperp powered by
carbs on dozens of
environments. Okay. Vectorization
synchronous and asynchronous parallel
uh
parallel simulation at millions of steps
per second. Our multiprocessing back and
has native multi-ent support be over 10x
faster than gymnasiums for some
environments. Emulation compatibility
tools that make working with complex
environments a breeze. Your environments
will still be in gymnasium pending zoo
format, but it will use a subset of the
API that is easier for most libraries to
deal with. Even if you use nothing else
from puffer, this layer is worth your
time. That last sentence is dumb, but
whatever. Ocean, our first party suite
of ultra performant environments written
in C. These are native puffer end of API
and each run 1 mil plus steps per second
per CPU core. New environment
contributions welcome.
This tutorial contains everything you
need to start doing RL 100x faster than
most of the field. We also highly
encourage you to read the puffer lip
source. It's not like other RL
libraries. Puffer does what it does in a
few thousand lines of very simple code.
It's also much easier to get help when
you're stuck. Our Discord community is
active and helpful. All right, so
like this is decent information, I
guess. Is this where this goes?
go. Hey,
Plasma. Very exciting doc writing
stream. What would users possibly not
want? Like what would be unclear or
confusing about
this? Does this not give a good overview
of what Puffer Lib
does? Are you updating the docs? I'm
working on it. I'm thinking how to like
first of all to update and then second
of all, how do I make [ __ ] like simple
and easy to follow, right? Like how do I
make stuff easier for everyone? And I
hate writing docs. So the only way I can
force myself to do this is to like is to
stream it basically. Otherwise, it'll
just sit here and not do it.
learn. But let's see. Do we have
insufficient examples
here? We have all
these. We have all
these. It could look more elegant. Yeah.
But what what does that
mean? Right.
examples. Well, Ray Lib maintains a
massive freaking number of examples,
right?
This is just these aren't like these are
just examples of like
um running our
demo. I mean like for building
environments, right? Every single one of
our environments is an example.
What if people
want RMS with a custom PyTorch neural
net? That's the whole That's all of our
code, isn't it? That's what all of our
code
like an example of using RMS without our
policy.
Um, I'm trying to think structurally how
the hell we do that, right? Cuz
like I guess then it's like we want you
want to load in like an external end and
pass it to our trainer or whatever.
okay. So that's not even docks. That's
like I got to make that thing something
we can easily do cuz like right now it's
like you go edit the torch file
right or that
This is definitely not enough on the
training demo for
uh for the new version.
So I mean what I what do we want here? I
guess it's like you pip install puffer
lib. You can call puffl to do the
training script I guess
right run an end with the
default customizer. The def
Well, but like what does it mean? Run
it, right? Like train
it or does it
mean Well, it depends, right? Like you
can use clean RL which is just like you
know a third of the length of our train
file and get ridiculously slow training
with like bad logging support and no
checkpointing and no sweeps and none of
the other
stuff. Right.
which is like the cleaner LPO Atari like
you can do that but like and like I
guess we can provide that like the file
is there and then with ours well the
demo script is gone it's all clean puff
now it's one
script so like what I've been trying to
work on
here what I've been trying to make
easier
here and we provide our own version of
the cleaner
script and we
provide so I have two things here
right that's using puffer lib yes so
this is clean rl we did this right so
here's it's 295 lines this has been here
since the previous version as well and
like this is clean rl with just a few
lines changed
commented as well. Where is
it? Find
[Music]
it. Right here. Hopper lib
vectorization. So, I did
this, but
like the problem I have with this
example is it's just like it's so much
worse than using our trainer.
Right? Like it's almost not even useful
to do this in some sense. Like I was
thinking of leaving this example
in. Well, we do have our trainer. Our
trainer is right here. Uh where is it?
So this is our trainer. It's 894
And then the actual training code for
this right we have is it we have clean
puffer it initializes all the experience
buffer stuff has
muon and I mean there's going to be more
code here because we have learning rate
schedule we have am support we have
logging you know we have all sorts of
[Music]
profiling we have an example of using
this
learner that's all the examples
20 well 20 was the demo.py. I deleted
demo.py and demo.py is now just here
right it's just been integrated with
this
code. What if I want to make my own
Python
script? So I mean this is the main
function right here.
I mean, it sounds like you just want
like importable version of this, I
guess, right?
It's a little annoying cuz like you have
to load in a pretty substantial config.
of
recipes. What recipes
I haven't had anybody say that they're
particularly helpful and then I just
have a [ __ ] notebook to maintain
which is like notebooks are awful.
They're just like horribly slow bloated
pieces of code.
RMS. I guess the confusion is
like so in my mind that is this script,
right? And where like this is one script
here. Well, I I actually do want to
understand what you want here because
this is valuable user feedback, but I'm
trying to like because like in my mind,
this was the point of this script,
right? In which I literally took what
normally takes like a 50,000line library
or whatever. Like if you go look up
here, if you go open like
SP3, all right, if I go like open this
code and like I just start clicking
[ __ ]
right? Yeah, I can I can totally jump on
Hello. Hey, how's it going? You hear me?
Yeah, I hear you. I'm trying to figure
out how to make this thing better. It's
just It's tough cuz like Yeah. I
Is what you're asking for basically like
can you just put all this stuff behind
an API so we can like import and call
it? Kind of. Yeah. Like for me when I
started like trying to contribute an an
instinct was okay how do I get basically
this basic PO to
to get like connect this the PO that we
have to my ENV just the very basics I
don't want all this argument uh parsing
and all this blah blah blah blah blah
with um that demo.py Pi has. So I was
like, how do I make something that's
like the smallest amount of code
possible that will run my env uh yeah,
which is which is kind of what I think
would be useful for people because um at
least from my understanding um what
Puffer Lib Puffer Lib helps with is it
allows people to create their own
environments and train it with our own
um PO or like um policy and sweeps and
whatever. ever uh else or they can
create their own they they can use one
of our enms and train it on one of their
custom PyTorch networks or something.
They can use their network but the thing
is our trainer is so much better than
everything out there. Like if you just
write your own train code it's just not
going to work.
That's like or if you just use SP3 or
use clean it's just straight up not
going to work. Like it'll just be slow
and it won't work. like we've actually
gone so far ahead of like of all the
default training implementations at this
point and like the thing is so like when
you're saying like the simplest possible
amount of code like if I just start
clicking around in like stable baselines
3 and keep in mind these are like very
very slow implementations of standard
algorithms right okay so if I just click
around here like I've got popppy oh look
it's only 283 lines except wait a second
it imports rollout buffer on policy
algorithm actor critic CNN and script it
imports all this stuff. So then like
okay so I have to click in here and I
have to go to common and now I have to
like look how they have this what's an
on policy algorithm okay now this
imports all this like I will be clicking
here for the next four hours
right so like I like here this is let's
look at this this is 894 lines which is
like a good number of lines right this
imports
torch this imports puffer lip and from
popular lib I have sweeps I have
vectorization I have some pytor utils
there's no other highle stuff like there
is no experience buffer being imported
here there's no like base algorithm
class there's no neural net a like all
of this stuff all that stuff is
contained in this 894 lines so like yes
this is in my mind it's like I've put so
much time I've probably put hundreds of
hours at this point into like trying to
make this as small and simple as
possible. So it's like I yes I can give
you I can give you a 50-line thing that
will run or less right that will let you
have a policy run it on your end with
our vectorzation yes and do inference
it's not going to train okay I could
give you this clean RL script here which
is right here or not this one this is
the standard clean RL script with PO
uh this is going to be like minimum 10x
slower probably way more than that won't
have logging won't have sleep sweeps
won't have all our new algorithm stuff.
Won't have anything that makes our stuff
work. So like what's going to happen is
you'll you can play with this thing for
months and you just like we'll get worse
results than you get out of the box with
our thing. So like that's the thing that
I don't know what to do with, right? Cuz
it's like oh just can we make it
simpler? Can we make it simpler? It's
like I've tried I've like I've already
compressed I've already compressed what
every other library has like at minimum
5,000 10,000 lines of code. it's already
less than a thousand.
So kind of what I mean by simpler is I
don't want you to compress something
like I don't want you to simplify
inherit complexity or necessary
complexity. Um but if you go back to
that example of the clean puffer RL uh
file. So I've taken every single thing
out of this file like I I basically
removed all the options on this. Like
there aren't like a ton of different
supported code paths. There may be like
a a few small things with switches left,
but this is pretty much like the this is
what most users should want for whatever
problem they're going to solve. See the
main function.
Yeah. So here is
I mean the main function is let's see
how long. So this is 821 line
821 down to
uh 1040. So 220 lines and this
includes so there's a bunch of
arguments.
Okay, you see yeah so you see all this
stuff. So what I so what I want as
someone who just wants to kind of start
in is I don't care about argument
parsing. I want literally as statically
as possible
um kind of um a train um a training
script that is completely static that
doesn't have anything uh other than the
training logic like uh the PO stuff or
um whatever policy um and the
vectorzation the end vectorization and
such that's all I want. I don't want any
argument parsing. I don't want any
config files. I want just the simplest
of simplest. It might not be the best
practice, but it'll help me kind of
understand the core uh concepts of the
project. And then from there, I can look
at the at what you have currently and be
like, okay, yeah, there there all this
argument stuff is importing these kind
of stuff. And instead of putting five
there, it it's actually importing it and
it's getting it from the uh like command
line arguments. Does that kind of make
sense? VRL does for that. They have this
thing here which is just they use Tyro,
but like this is basically just arg
they have all in they're not loading
config files. They have to hardcode
everything in here, right? With all the
defaults. So we could do that right with
ours. But then this is what happens if I
do that. So uh basically this is how
this is how long our config files are.
Okay. This is how long our config our
config is 183 lines.
Okay. So like I see. And it's also this
thing. If I put those in the defaults, I
have to write those same. Like I guess
technically I can have that be the
default instead of having a default
file, right? But then I still have all
the other M's, every single M is still
going to have its own config file. Okay.
So kind of what I'm saying. So you know
how you have a default config that kind
of when you have your own env config um
it takes that own env and whatever
arguments are passed in that envirrites
in this default or whatever like
overrites those. What if you keep that
default in config the um for the example
but then let people overwrite it like
basically overwrite the only the kind of
most important uh arguments uh
statically so or like the exact I can
totally do that hypothetical the thing
is the one the reason I don't have that
and the reason I've actually tried to
pull more things into this config file
is because arg parse is kind of [ __ ] um
Um, so like this is how long the code is
with arg parse. Like argar doesn't just
let you def like write something like it
is in a config. Arg parse looks like the
heck is it?
Argar is like parser add argument name
as a string type default and then
there's a like help and then for
booleans there's like the store true
thing like there's more stuff. It's
annoying. Yes, it's I'd have 183 lines
of this. I agree. And actually, this
doesn't even support this does not even
support nested stuff. So like I have to
make it like Yes. Yeah. It's Jen with
lists and stuff. Yeah. It's annoying. I
agree. And that's why I want that
removed. I What I'm saying is that So
then do you want you don't want me to
put the config here then?
What I want you to not have arc parse at
all and just statically in the file
override um override whatever you need
to kind of like um how a lot of like
PyTorch tutorials do it is when they
create like a neural network they don't
read the layer sizes and all that from a
config file or from an arc parse. They
literally just set it. Yes. And that's
what as a it might it's not the best
practice but as a intro it's good
because it takes that mental overhead of
having argument parsing and all that
stuff. It allows the person to focus on
the main concept which is the
vectorization and the policy and we had
this at some point. So the way that this
would look, right, what you're asking
for there, the way that would look like
is the defaults for this thing. This
function would now have 50 arguments.
What do you mean? Well, it would either
be I'd have 50 lines of globals here,
right? Okay. Yeah. And that's not I
can't even overwrite that from arg
anymore. Now I have to have a separate
script because I'd have to like I I'd
have to like get the string by I'd have
to do some jank meta stuff in order to
like map the hardcoded stuff to that. So
what I'm saying is not is take away the
arc parse but not the argument file not
the
file keep that and only for example like
when I run my end I configure like and I
can tell you I'm configuring like seven
arguments seven uh like 10 arguments max
um everything else is is fetched from
that default uh file so I think what I I
would ideally like is like a script
where there is it still reads the
default config and okay you know does
all the default stuff um basically and
then only over and then the hard-coded
parameters overwrite specific parts of
the default if that makes sense. One
second just link link me a loss curve if
you want me to look at it. Um,
so here I could, so technically, and
I've played with this, um, I can
just move all of these into config
files, right?
Okay. So like I see. Okay. So what I'm
saying is I want also a script that is
not that is very static in the sense of
like the environment. I want that
hardcoded. I want my environment to be
just let's say breakout, right? And then
my uh mode I I want it to be um
statically coded as train, right? And so
you can remove a
lot, right? But path, you know what I
mean? Kind of thing. Yeah, it's kind of
tough because like if you want to do
anything your your work loop on like
let's say even the simplest possible
thing that a new contributor would want
to do, right? Which is get an NV working
like make an
env train on their new end. So like what
you would do for that is you write your
M, you maybe you write a test, maybe you
manually debug, right? You like get your
M to run. You're going to do a couple of
basic training runs. Maybe you're going
to want to evalot to see like what the
policy is doing. And then you're going
to run a sweep.
Okay, I see. And the sweep requires a
config file and adjust hyperparameters
for So like basically as soon as you go
through the next thing, it's like you
immediately outgrow that entire demo and
I just have to copy paste the whole
file.
Yes. Okay. Um, okay. That's an Yeah,
that's an interesting point. So, like I
really really care about this stuff.
Like I want to minimize complexity, but
I'm trying to figure out what the what
the [ __ ] curve. So So what I think would
be cool is I think this is where Weston,
what you can't give me a graph that
doesn't have any [ __ ] labels on the
axis, man. and expect me that like
sometimes I'm telepathic and I can just
guess your problem and tell you what
line of code it is. I've done that a
good number of times, but like you got
to at least give me access labels for me
to have a chance of doing that.
All right,
good. I think that's a reward. I think
the axis is But like what what is he
sent me a histogram? Like I've never
seen a histogram in RL in my
life.
Listen, he's ahead. He's ahead. Okay.
He's uh
The blue one looks like it works for a
while and then something breaks.
Google Sheets.
Why are you making graphs in Google
Sheets?
Oh my god. Lesson, I need to look. Look,
man. We need to get you on a proper tech
stack, okay? It's like one of the best
things you can do. I know you're like
earlier on. So it's like one of the best
things we can do is get you on a proper
text stack. That doesn't mean hand you a
bunch of bloated tools. It means you
give you like the minimum number of
things so you cannot be making plots in
[ __ ] Google Sheets. All right. Pick.
If you want to do it locally, use either
Mattplot lib or plotly or I've been
using dash lately. Those are all fine.
If you want to not have to deal with any
of that [ __ ] and just have it done for
you instantly. Get a web tool. You can
do even tensorboard will do it for you
locally and also in browser. You can get
Wandi. Wandi is fine. Neptune
technically they still have free
accounts. Neptune's been pretty good
lately. If you have to find it on their
web page, but you can sign up for still
free accounts. Like do one of these and
just log to there. You'll be happier.
Yeah, 100%. I I Yeah, I'm going to
berate him a little bit so that he
learns because I wish somebody had told
me this [ __ ] when I was starting be like
because man, I did way stupider [ __ ]
than this. All right. And nobody was
like, "Oh, that's so cool." It's like,
"No, dude. What are you doing?" You want
You want to hear a stupid uh thing I
did? I So, I did not know how to display
graphics really. So, what I did is I
built a um breakout
envoting on it. And I've seen freaking
Top Labs use Mattplot LIIB as their
renderer. All right, that's not even
that bad.
No way. I don't
Top Labs as their renderer. Let's go.
All right, let's go. Look. All right,
researchers, they don't know [ __ ] Okay,
they know most researchers, they know
like a bunch of deep learning kung fu
and they know like either some linear
algebra or stats, probably not both. And
like they know a bunch of papers. That's
what we know. All right. Well, what most
of us know,
I guess. Yeah. I don't even know a
little bit of stats. All right. I You
know what I know is I know a little bit
of low-level dev. All right. Instead of
the instead of the math, and that's what
I get bugged on. Yeah, dude. But there's
some researchers with crazy math
knowledge.
And then you see the code that they
write. Is it normal to go that
high? Y equals loss. What loss? Policy
gradient loss. Like there are like four
different losses in RL.
Shouldn't it be uh normalized? Yeah.
Like I don't know. Like you can't just
say loss. It's is it entropy? Is it
polic reward? Is No, it said loss. So
like Oh, yeah. Yeah. You're right.
You're right.
Why are you even looking at this thing?
Except that it's crazy.
Well, yeah. Well, I'll answer I'll
answer. You just got to give me some
proper data. Yeah. So, yeah. Anyway,
yeah. So, what I was kind of saying with
the simplified script
is yes, I get that sweeps are like a
part of the library, but I think
introducing sweeps like right away like
might be not the best idea. I think
introducing concepts like and I think
what you were saying with copying the
whole thing, what you can do is not copy
the whole thing. You can have one file
that has all these examples and then in
your docs site have it kind of um I
don't know are you using like sphinx or
what are you using for docs? Uh we
finally we got rid of sphinx now it's
just it's HTML CSS and a little bit of
JavaScript.
Ah okay. Well, what I was saying is what
if you kind of have um like kind of
intro like create something that
introduces it step by step if that makes
sense. So like um here is like just us
training it in the dumbest way kind of
thing like an environment and then this
is how now we introduce sweeps. This is
now how we introduce like XYZ. You know
what I mean? Um I've tried so many
versions of this. It's like so hard to
get one of these that like a works and
then b is not immediately outdated as
soon as I start hacking on dev. Yes,
that's why I like stuff like uh the the
the autod do stuff cuz then I do
something and then I build and it picks
it up from the
Yeah. But yeah, the sphinx just wasn't
worth it in my opinion. Like we had it
in our old site here. I think I can
even have it on internet archive.
No, it's still technically hosted.
So the oops this is
slashdev. So this is like our old 10
site here and like you can see it was
like way heavier than the old one and we
had like these autogen things that
weren't really well filled out and like
you could scroll through but like does
scrolling through this don't do anything
better for you than scrolling through
the code? Yeah, good point. Uh but I
think you know what the the the the code
um I think what would be good here this
is this is we had like this is how you
use emulation we had like stuff like
this
I I don't think people liked it like I
did stuff like this where like
this was like this is how you this is
actually this is how you use a policy
right with and this is how you get
actions from a policy I think that's
actually really nice. I'm not going to
lie. You can do something like that.
That's easy. Don't we still have that?
What what you can do is instead of
having it like this in a file like that,
what you can do is instead of having it
in a website, you can just have it those
explanation texts in comments. So create
one example file with bunch of
comments as like explanations if that
makes
sense. And like oh yeah, this is the
example I have here, right?
The default policy is too long. But
yeah, cuz I just copied. That looks
good. That looks good. Um I think what
though is will be helpful with this is
um more comments like um Okay. So yeah,
we have the policy. Now how do we
connect it to like the let's see do you
connect it to a an environment here?
Yes, you do. You do vector make. Okay.
Yeah. So all these things I think this
is good. It just needs to be commented
better for for um not in your
uh I like how it's commented for source
code right now. Like as a contributor, I
like this like as a new user. Fill it
out with comments. Explain every little
line.
Um just so the user um can have it and
understand it for the first time better.
Well, my favorite thing about this is I
get to delete half of it now cuz like
I've made it simpler since like all
these cleaner things are gone. You got
you got to split the loss up and figure
out which of those is exploded. One of
those is completely exploded.
Yeah, if you can if you can take this is
this is the exact example I want like
this with just more comments. But like
this still doesn't tell you how training
works or sweeps or anything, right? This
is like right and so it's like a little
rough because actually here like I can
delete most of the stuff from this
default file. The thing is, you notice
that we don't have um there's no puffer
lib base class here, right? This is
straight up just any freaking PyTorch
network that returns actions and values.
Ah, so like there isn't an API. It's
like you're looking for an API, but we
don't have one because I like like you
don't want another API to learn, so I
didn't make one, right? Like that's the
point. Okay. Okay. So, how would you do
the same thing you did here but with uh
Well, I think I already know the answer
to this question. Weston, it's people do
that for three years straighten their
PH. Like, dude, RL's freaking hard. All
right. Like, what you are you running
this stuff on uh on Puffer? Because if
you're not, like it's going to be hard.
Like, I'll look at like you can link me
some stuff at some point. All
right. Okay. That's why it's not
working. Just run the damn thing on a
puffer trainer and then you won't have
to guess whether your training code is
wrong, which I'm sure it is, or your end
code is wrong, which it may or may not
be.
Okay. So, how let's say um for example,
this is probably a good um thing for
Weston here. What like if he had an
example of here we go, this is a puffer
trainer. Um this is how you run a puffer
trainer on this env. Um, now switch it
with your end and you're good. What I
was thinking for that, here's what I was
thinking for that. So, you know how we
have, first of all, people have been
asking for me to make this thing pip
installable so that you can run our
trainer without having to clone the
GitHub. Okay. Yes. So, I did that. So
what happens now is when you uh when you
pip what's going to happen is when you
pip install puffer lib if you just run
pufferl from the command line it's the
same thing as running like python clean
pufferl.py.
Ah okay. So then and you can apply all
the same arguments. So what I was going
to do and I have to add a couple lines
of code to do this because if people
want the feature I have to add a couple
lines of code, right? But right now the
configs it looks uh it looks in this
configs directory, right?
What I was going to do is I was going to
make it also look in your directory
where you run this command from. So if
you put a conf if you put ain file in uh
in your directory where you run this
command from it'll look for it and it'll
try to like load from that or if you put
like a torch.py file if you put a model
file in there it'll like you can load
from there or if you put like your n
file in there you can import the end
from there. So I was thinking of doing
that so that like instead of like now
just open folder.folderfolder
folder.folder and like edit the code in
there. It's like yeah, you can put your
model file here. You can put whatever
and then I can just give like a little
example project or whatever that's like
using Puffer or
whatever where you can just like clone
the Puffer example project instead of
all of Puffer Lib and it has like you
know three super basic files in it with
like a dummy environment and like a um
you know a dummy policy and like a dummy
config and then it just like it runs
with that.
Um, so I get what you're saying, but I
again I think going and this might be
wrong, but I think going the
um more of the kind of uh importable way
would be better. Um
like I messed up. So it's so hard
because you know that forces me to
commit to an API that's going to change
repeatedly. Yes, I see. Um, this was
kind of my compromise because it's like
giving an entry point like a command
like pufferell. You kind of get that
we're just running the demo script, but
you still don't have to clone the whole
repo to set it up. Well, technically
it's an API kind of, right? It's not
programmable. It just like a you know,
it's a demo script more than anything,
right? It's like it's just our current
train
script. One feels worse than the other,
right? one feels if you're writing code
and cuz like you're writing code and
you're importing [ __ ] from the API and
then the entire thing is completely
different the next update that seems
like it feels worse than the script that
you ran has changed
right I mean I don't know like I find
that I don't know I'm I'm more
comfortable working with like with code
like that more than um than having it as
like a ash like as a shell command
basically because that's kind of what
you have right now. You basically have
somewhat of an a function in the shell
if that makes sense. So like like let's
say I want to create a for loop. Yeah, I
can create it in bash with the demo or
with a clean
puffer.py but it'll be much easier for
me to be able to do that in Python and
then involve
pan. You know what I mean? You can
technically import this if you want to,
but like you know how how much fun are
you going to have doing that without
having this main function?
Um well that main function the
only function does right this loads all
the configs and then for sweeps this has
this has the loop for running sweeps in
it. Mhm. So this has like this like you
figure this actually will figure out
what type of sweep you want to run. It
will set it up for you. It runs
everything. So yeah, it's only 20 lines
of code, but it does all this.
Um like I the alternative is that I put
this into a sweep function that you can
import I guess. Uh so I guess what I'm
kind of saying is you know how you have
here a main function that's uh basically
has no arguments nothing in it and all
the arguments are kind of fetched within
it with the um with a config file with
the like statically set config file or
searched config file. Yeah, it's cuz if
I if I type all the arguments out there
just there are billion of them. I I
don't like having this config thing
either. It's just a dictionary first of
all. Like this thing gets parsed as a
dictionary and like Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm not complaining about that. What I'm
complaining about is let's say I mean um
actually no I want to understand this
cuz the goal of this is not to be right.
Right. Like the goal of this is to
change it cuz like the thing is like it
needs to be different and easier. I just
don't know how because I've tried it
like a dozen different ways. Right. Yes.
Okay. I I'll then um I'm I'm sharing my
screen right now and I'm gonna So is
this clean puffer RL on dev branch right
now?
See what we got.
What branch are you on right now? Dev
branch. Clean puffl. And it's on uh
that's Oh, it's it's not the dev branch
here. That's not the dev branch. That's
your fork. That's your fork of the dev
branch. That's my fork. Correct.
Okay.
It's been quite You're going to see
actually I I just want you to see the
change in the amount of stuff that's
there. Way less stuff. Yeah. Wait,
that's not that's still not it. That's
still not it. That's 20 branch. Go to
dev. Oh, correct.
Okay. Watch all the files disappear.
Nice. This is nice. So, I'm working on
it. I try very hard. No, this is good.
What what I'm saying is uh I'm just
going to copy this and kind of show you
um what I was thinking more.
So right now you have this um where
basically the main function here um
basically takes all the arguments here,
right? Yeah. Yeah. That's gonna get
that's getting fixed. Yeah. What I was
thinking is what if you have all of
this, right? all of this argument
parsing you move it down to here and
then you have main function take those
arguments so the whatever args it takes
arg or whatever right from the arc
parser well the only that the reason
that that like that def main was an if
like the only reason I have main and the
if statement is because entry points
requires that yes it requires it for
multipprocessed Python yes so it's not
It's not even the multiro. It's just the
entry point thing. Yes, it well actually
Python doesn't require this as entry
point. At least to my knowledge, Python
only requires this when you're running
uh like multipprocessing when you're
doing multipprocessing because then it
doesn't know which file to start running
cuz it doesn't know which one is the
main like which one is the so for
example let's say um I have a
multipprocess that imports this like a
multi uh like I use the multipprocess
Python package that imports this you
know I'm referring to something
different here I'm referring to like the
setup.py thing like the entry point
where you can export a shell command to
do a to call a function. You can't
export a shell command that calls
underscore main. It has to call an
actual function. So if I do it that way
by the way like since entry points can't
call this then it can't call arg parse.
So that means that you will not be able
to pass arguments to the transcript.
I see. Okay.
So, so what I kind of want, at least in
my opinion, is to have kind of what you
have here is you have an arc parse
version. All of this I can delete all
that and put it in the config.
This
well maybe in the config, but I don't
know. Oh, I I just think that what if
you have even if you don't delete it and
put in a config, what if you have
something like I don't know like let's
say this is
um I don't know call it like uh like
you'll have um what's called uh you'll
have CLI main which is basically this
and then you'll have like main main
which basically takes in all these
arguments as key as keyword arguments.
So you'll have well there like 180 of
like it's not just those. Well you have
n but what I'm saying is I'm not saying
the ones from so what you do is you have
like n all those and then at the end you
have config path. So here are is the
path to the config file that'll have all
the hundreds of arguments. Right? That's
kind of what I'm thinking. What's the
point of having them in both places?
Like I can just put them all in config
and then not have all those in in main
at all. Right.
Um, yeah, that that is an option if you
don't want to have a CLI kind of there
is a CLI. Oh, do you not know how this
works? So, it's kind of cool. If you
scroll down a little bit, it's only like
30 lines of code. I've really tried to
compact this thing. That dynamic help
menu that takes every single thing that
it finds in the config file that you
specifically load and also turns it into
a CLI option option. So, everything in
your config can also be set via CLI.
Oh [ __ ] Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. I remember
that. I remember that. I worked very
like this thing used to be 300 lines. I
worked very hard to get it down to this
small. Like it's still annoying that
there's like 20 30 lines of code here,
but what this thing does, so this loads
in your default config and then it goes
to your main config. it will find it for
you, match it by end name, overwrite
defaults from both AR parse and the um
the default file with your args and then
make a CLI for you out of them.
Yes.
Okay. Okay. I mean, okay, that makes
sense. Um,
okay. So, I can take all these things
out of arguments and if I I can
technically put them all in config and
it will work. The only thing that's
slightly janky that I'd have to deal
with is um any files don't have types.
So like sometimes you'll put like false
for instance and it'll be like the
string false which evaluates to true.
Right. Right. So just to kind of
understand this uh all of this, all of
what I just highlighted and there's a
little more down here like this. All of
this is just argument parsing and
extraction, right? This is also config
loading. Yeah. And conf like that's what
I mean like config and command line
argument parsing and extraction. Yeah.
So this thing this it does all of that
and it also makes the config menu for
you.
It makes the like the CLI the CLI like
it makes the CLI for you as well from
config. Yes. Um but then after this the
only thing that you need after this is
these right. Yes. So what I'm saying is
have a function that does all of this.
So you have that fancy CLI args but then
also have an importable main function or
whatever you want to call it that
literally takes this just takes config
just or yeah takes config okay or or
args or takes args which is what you
have here right this is the only thing
that's kind of used past here you know
okay that makes sense kind of yeah cuz
Then you could pass like a config to
this. But then what do you what goes in
there? What goes in here? Mhm.
What? That's the thing that that's kind
of the beauty of it. You'll have it. Um
so yeah, you can get rid of you can get
rid of my So like I understand the value
in not having to read like my config
parsing. Um, so like if you just paste
everything below the loading into that
main function, is that better for you
now? Because I still have dynamic I have
still have a bunch of [ __ ] there.
Oh, so like you're saying like you have
like I just want you to see what it
looks like. Okay, so there's still a
bunch of [ __ ] right? So you see all
the dynamic import, right? Because what
this has to do is like if you're going
to specify the name of a policy in a
config file or you're going to specify
the name of an N, I have to go load that
thing, which means I have to use that as
the import path and I have to
dynamically import it. Yes. Oh crap.
There's a whole bunch of import crap
that's a little confusing here. Well, it
kind of makes sense. You're just saying
like if it's if it's ocean, use this
kind of thing. Well, but then it gets if
it's ocean or I also use this if it's
the Yeah, because you have uh you have
here something. Yeah. Okay. But what I'm
kind of saying terrible cuz like is I
Mhm. Is this better though? Is like that
easier now to read that it starts like
with this.
It's easier to read in the sense of like
let's say I'm a new person and I want um
I'm just going to create let's say
examples. You just don't want to have to
read my fancy config parsing. I guess
right yes exactly so like let's say I
can import uh main right and then I I
can just do main and I can give it my
end equals uh let's say I want to give
it my puffer
voids and then I give it mode
uh train and then I'm good to go. Does
that kind of make sense? So instead of
having instead of doing well yeah and
then like config path whatever in a
config thing you know something like
this you can't give it config path like
that cuz all my loading my loading has
to load the default and then load your
thing right you'd have to load the
config yourself manually now you see
um so wait okay let let me see what you
see like this is why it's like it's
tough cuz like you think oh now it's so
easy for me. But it's not cuz you forgot
about all the other stuff that I just
did for you. Oh, you were saying this?
Yeah, I have to load. So, what you do is
you make a config parser. You load the
innie. So, you you'd actually you'd have
to at least copy those two lines.
These two these two you mean these no
you need to do config parser and then
you have to do read config default any
and that actually now has to be the path
to the default in puffer lib where I'm
going to handle that path like the
global path and and this path so this is
the default right and you're saying here
this is the path of the default config
no right no no that's the default path
and then path is your config path yes so
what if you just
Um, I guess you're trying to iterate
over each. So, I do it for you. I like
basically. So, right now, like you can
copy those two lines, one and two. Well,
yeah, these two. Okay. So, you can copy
those two lines and you can put those in
your main function.
Yeah. So, in here kind of thing, I have
them I guess. Well, that's it'll be like
Yeah. Oh, no. It's got to be in the
function, right? It's too much. That's
not go that can't go in args. Yeah.
Right now like right now something like
this you know um okay but basically what
I'm saying is in well what you can do is
instead of doing this right since you're
doing all of this here what if you um
this path right it's just a string
right?
Well, then then my main function. No,
cuz you took you took my loading logic
out, right? You took What I'm saying is
what if you replace this with config
path?
Does that make sense? No. Um, main of
args. Hang on. Which which function is
this? Uh, wow. Where am I? Oh, okay. I
need to go back to main. Main. Here we
go. Main of args. Uh, okay. So, here
Oh, no. I think I think I was looking I
wanted to look at this one. This one.
Yeah, this one. This. Yeah. Yeah, this
one. So, what I was saying is what if
you um make this path into config path
like that? But now you're calling But
now you're no longer calling my You're
calling CLI main, not main.
No, no, no. What I'm what I'm saying is
main passes that to um well CLI main
calls main. Ah I see. So we'll have to
put um so you wanted to call main not
CLI main. So CLI main has my extra
loading. What I'm saying here right is
you're like oh then I can just pass my
path. I'm like no no no you can't just
pass the path because the loading
happened before that right and like the
reason it happened before that the
reason that you wanted to get rid of it
is because it's complicated.
Good point. Let's
Yeah. So, yeah, that I get where you're
saying this is kind of difficult, but I
guess what I would think what I would
compromise on is to kind of have
um Okay. So, I see. So, you're doing
that stuff. Okay.
Um Right. And then you're extracting
here. Oh, okay. I see.
So what if you have
and this doesn't even have validation by
the way which I really wish we had
config validation but we don't like if
you typo an arc right now you're
screwed. Yes. Yes. Um okay so what kind
of I was thinking
is so I think I just copied it. I don't
think I like removed um the this stuff
from CLI main. But besides that point,
what Okay, so what I would kind of want
from main then would be basically
um this I go and I
I
main here we go. So, I want that with
all this stuff and then um
Well, then I then I literally can't then
you kill my CLI demo then, right? Right.
That's what
I That's where I that's where you know
how you have um and I think what's you
got to do is uh ah right the CLI demo
allows you to change stuff from the
config, right? God damn it. You're
right.
Okay. Yeah. Uh okay. Yes. Okay. Okay.
Let me think
here. I see. Um so it's like I see it's
so tough cuz like I see you're trying to
simplify things. Yes. I like I see the
way that in which you're trying to
simplify things. But it's like I've
literally spent so long on this and it's
like it's been so simplified that
basically everything you're doing is
stuff like I've tried at some point and
then I've realized that it actually
creates more complexity because now I
have to like handle it two ways instead
of one.
I see. Cuz you know what this sounds
like? This sounds um very similar to the
problem with having stuff like PyTorch
Lightning or KAS. you have this kind of
main training function or whatever that
does everything and then when you want
to do something a little bit different,
you know, you kind of uh you just it's
it just becomes so what I think would be
but like the cool thing with this is at
least the way that you're supposed to be
able to do that is you're you can
actually edit the script because you
have one file and it's relatively short
instead of having 500 files that don't
make any sense.
So what I think a different approach to
this would be is um you know how I kind
of approached the thing where I had
basically I was like you know what I
just want one function to call and it
just does my thing here like this right?
Mhm.
What if you have instead of a function
like this, you have like
um um kind of like
a like you functionize the um the
argument parsing and the uh config
parsing if that makes sense. So like um
you know how here you have um all the
argument parsing. So you want like a
load config function. Yeah kind of like
a load. I can do that and then let's but
let's see how short that that can get.
So let's say I give you load config
which will load from a file and
optionally if you take arguments it will
also be able to be overrided from
command line. Yeah I can do that for
you. So what let's say you had um let's
say this um okay so how about instead of
config like this so I think what's
really missing right now is having one
unified kind of well I guess you do have
it it's called um args so if we look at
args um this args right this is kind of
the
unified arguments that all all the
arguments that are needed right so what
I think is if you can make it so that
you can um I can give you that like that
thing right there that args that gets
loaded. I can make that a function that
loads that for you either from a config
or a like that's fine. So that's just
taking the first like 50 lines of uh my
main function or whatever and separating
it out. So I can do that just fine. But
then the problem is there's still not
really any good way to make like a
really easy short demo out of this
stuff.
Um because like of all the dynamic stuff
below it. So like technically I guess
for any 1M like yeah I could probably
make it for you so that your main file
looks like you know load config and then
it probably looks like you know
instantiating your policy and then it
looks like a ve make or whatever. Um,
and then it looks like, you know,
instantiate clean puffer and call. Like
I can probably get it to look like that.
Uh, I don't know, something like this.
Like that's what you're talking about,
right? Well, you don't even need at that
point. You don't have to call main,
right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You just have
Let's get rid of that. Yeah. So, like,
let's say that let's say that you just
like let's say that you have you want
your own M or my M? Uh, let's say you
want to Yeah. Let's say you have your
kind of um you have your own custom
environment. Can I use the Yeah, sure.
Let me let me show you. Do you have the
stream up? Uh yes. Okay. I'm going to
type You keep the stream muted, but just
take a look at what I'm Yep. typing and
let me just ban this freaking
bot. I make the bots here. No more
Twitch bots.
All right.
And so this is what I can do for you,
right? So like
All right. So, we do like import uh from
puffer liib import
pufferell. Okay. And then like what do
you want your environment or my
environment? Puffer lilib.pufferl import
star or something like that. Uh so yeah
let's let's have uh I guess uh or yeah
uh we can have like let's say do you
want your environment or my environment?
Yeah let's say I want my envi like my
own custom environment that is um but
you know what for simplicity probably it
will be simpler to have your kind of
already builtin environment. Um so let's
go with puffer lib environment and
puffer lib policy. Okay I just want to
train a puffer lib environment with
puffer lib policy. So we do this and
then we do upper lib
import. Okay. So in that case then we'll
do like
n
creator we'll
ocean dot
uh what I creator like uh breakout
or something. Yeah. Yeah. Something like
that. Okay. And then we do let's say
args
equals hover like uh load
config config. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Config.
Yes. Exactly. And then we do let's see.
So we do
policy equals puffer lib dot do we want
models
let's import it. Yeah let's just do
hypothetical for example like you know
it doesn't have to run right now but
like
models sure and then it's probably like
Uh now this is a little like STM or
something like that, right? It has to
take uh it has to take the N by default.
So we have to do like back end.
Oh okay. So this is going to be like
puffer lib dot. Yeah. And now you have
to import this.
I usually I just do it this way, right?
And then you give it uh env creator and
then like
args like numbum ms
etc.
Yes. Yes. Okay. But now like do you want
do you want like a custom backend or do
we want to just because we could
technically do like numbum ms equals 4
and then we could do backend equals
pufferlib.
[Music]
multi-processing.
Okay. So, it doesn't have to take your
m. So, we can just ignore the stuff
that's in the innie and just use Yeah.
All right. So, here this gives you Wait,
wait, wait. Okay. So, where uh where am
I using my config then? Okay. I guess
this is what I'm showing you. is like
I'm trying to see if this is still good
cuz you're going to see like the places
where stuff is is still a little screwy
cuz M do I think like driver M or
whatever because it needs it needs an M
to like infer your model space and then
I can do like hidden size equal 128
whatever else and then let's say I want
an LSTM. So we do lstm policy equals
puffer liib.m models.lstm
LSTM
wrapper driver end like policy something
like this
right uh okay so I kind of have an idea
for the args like the load config kind
of dynamic with the veend
um so you know how you have like the
load config takes in your config path
like your string config path well I can
do if you're thinking of Like I can do
starst star args of uh like vector or
something. Is that good? Um what do you
mean by that? Oh, so like I can do this
but there's a problem.
This is going to be a string in the
config which is what the dynamic imports
are for. Yes. Right. You see like how I
run and your load config is what checks
and loads the config and makes it typed
and make it or some of it is but then
some of it's underneath it. So like I
can do this you have your policy now and
then I can do like
um I hate the abstraction of trainers so
damn much but I guess that's what it is.
No, you don't have to. You can just
can't you just forward loop it?
Well, it has to have
state and it's probably something like
this, right?
[Music]
Okay. Okay. And then I can do or and I
do actually have a for loop which is one
thing I I do like in range args or I
think it's like
while
trainer not trainer something like this
or whatever or it's like yeah there's
something I think it's more like while a
trainer.global global
step less than
args total train
steps like there's something like
this and then you do trainer evealuate
trainer
train blah blah
blah like I can do something like
this this doesn't tell you much because
these functions are freaking hiding
everything Right. Right.
Um so what I was Okay, but this is I
think like um at least for me as a
beginner going to a library um
this like everything anyways, right? No,
what I like is I think PyTorch got it
like the best in my opinion where they
got the right level of of abstraction
like you can still see, you know what I
mean? Like you can Yeah. Okay. I agree.
No, I agree with you. And the thing is
anything that's anything higher level
than PyTorch is garbage. Which is why
PieTorch Lightning sucks and Cara sucks.
Like these are both these are both
libraries for dumb industry hacks. Like
Yes. And that's we want to be the
PyTorch, you know. Yeah, I know. But the
thing that's tough here, right, is
like the stuff that's in RL is not the
same as you building your train loop.
Right. Right. Because if you look at the
stuff that we have to do in
reinforcement learning compared to like
everywhere else,
[Music]
this is why like this is why I have it
in a file, right? Yeah. Are you talking
about like sweeps? Not even that. Like
we have
that. All right, let's just look at the
stuff in here. Like the amount of crap
that I have to set. So first of all,
there's some backends where if you don't
set these, you magically lose
performance, right? There's
reproducibility stuff. Um, now we need
an interactive environment. This is not
like a load data set. This is an
interactive and asynchronous
environment.
Um, we have a big statically allocated
buffer with a ton of different things in
it.
Okay, this is your experience buffer.
Mhm. Right. Normally everything has a
big class for this thing as well. We
just have this. We have you need LSTM
state if you want to use an LSTM. That
also needs to be pre-allocated or else
it's slow.
Um,
yeah. for I see for optimization and
stuff like that you need to Yeah. And so
like there's also now there's like all
this mini batching stuff in calcs
because we have calcs the mini batch
size is actually and the like the batch
sizes are based on the number of
environments you have and like this
rollout length. It's not like in
supervised learning. All right. Now
we've got torch compile. This actually
can go away because we're going to
probably just end up dropping atom
because muan's just better. But now we
have you know fancy optimizer. Um that's
fine. We have learning rateuler. All
right. So, we have to do our learning
rateuler.
We have automatic mix precision. We have
logging.
And then we have this uh this monitoring
down. Okay. So, this I feel like this
logging kind
of Okay. So, okay. I like everything I
see kind of besides the logging because
it's like platform specific. It would be
cool if you can just pass in a logging
module and you know what I mean like
like a logging class with specific
methods or something like well I don't
like call back in general I think
callbacks is really [ __ ] design but like
let's say instead of giving you call
backs like after you call evaluate you
can add your own logging that's fine the
thing is our logging is really freaking
good um yes um like the dashboard in
particular the dashboard this I added
Let's see how much code this is. So this
function here is like 100 something
lines of code, right? So yeah, this
gives you when you
train. So if I just do
puffel, if I just even call this with
default arcs. Mhm. This does this for
you
and you get your metrics here and any
end will have your metrics. Like
anything that's in infos, you'll have
your metrics. And this is kind of like a
major selling point of buffer as well
because like this thing gives you so
much more visibility than like basically
everything else out there in RL. So like
I could take it out. I could not make it
the default but then you're going to
suffer. That's not a logging I'm talking
about. I'm more talking about the
experiment tracking like the Neptune. So
Neptune I can take out. Neptune Neptune
I can technically take out and I've been
playing with doing that. So in that case
what it would be is it would go here. So
I have this experiment. So this is kind
of like the code you wanted to write
over
puffer. I could put it
here. So okay where um so you um go back
to the Neptune and weights and biases uh
kind of code um where you kind of uh log
to them. Yeah. So you see here you have
like if Neptune if LF weights and
biases. What if instead of having that
you basically get a experiment tracker
class or or like backend um that you can
literally get in the function that is a
class that implements specific functions
is I guess that's I think that's too
high level. I'm good with taking I'm
good with taking it out of here. So I'm
good with taking it out like that that
could be potentially fine I think. But
then what I would do is I would just
paste this into experiments.
I see. And what when does experiments
get called? It just gets called from
main.
Okay. So like now honestly experiment
like you wouldn't even call experiment.
Like you would just write this code like
I would put this code into your
demo right? So if I just do
Okay, let me see. Ah, okay. This is
actually really nice. Yes, this is Yes,
exactly. and move and move the all the
like cuz what I I kind of am worried
about with like Neptune or um Weights
and Biases is a person who wants to log
their experiment and they don't want to
pay for weights and biases or for
whatever kind of thing or they they're
for let's say they both have free
accounts but yes yeah for let's say for
for work situation or they're in a
research lab that for some reason uses
MLflow
um and they want to use MLflow you know
Yeah, you can bring your own. That's
chill. That's easy for me to do. So,
like I I don't even like I was thinking
of doing that anyways. So, let's let's
say that we do that and then we do like
whatever you you'll just do um you know
your
logger.log stats uh and that'll go like
right. Okay. So, I do that's fine. Okay.
I'm chill with that. And then like the
you don't need to import experiment. Now
I do you care the fact do you care that
these two things are also ridiculously
high level? Which one eval
because I don't know how to make it any
like I don't know how to go lower level
than this. This is extremely high level
but I don't know how to go any lower
level than this because of all the stuff
we have to do and like honestly if I let
you do this yourself you'll do it slow.
Ah okay. I see what you mean. Like so
here death eval look like look what's
eval. All right. So, eval first of all,
all of our stats that we collect from
profiling, uh, they come from these
profiling mac, like these profiling
macros here. Um, okay. Macros kind of
macros. You see macros? Not exactly. So,
they're kind of funky in the sense that
they set this like they set the state of
the profiler to evalu.
Oh, it's like a state machine. Yeah. The
reason that we do it this way is because
before, let me show you how it looked in
20.
I think about every single one of these
things. Like I really really try to um
Mhm.
All right. So like look how gross this
code was with eval with eval. So
everything is indented under like
Yep. Yep. Yep. under under the context
thing. Yeah. So now what we have is you
just switch the profiler whenever you
want to and like it's no longer does
that. Yeah. No longer insanely invented.
Okay. And but we still have this this
crap cuz you know with statements like
Yeah. Yeah. With like PyTorch. It has
the context handling context. So we do
this. Um I probably can I might be able
to even clean up a little bit of this.
We'll see. But yeah, we have this and
then like
Yeah. So like this is the this is all
the stuff like this is the full eval but
like I don't know what lower level I
would give you here. Yes. Right. Um and
I think that's the thing though. I think
the problem you're running to is kind of
similar a similar problem that PyTorch
people are kind of running into. Uh and
their solution I think was compile if
that makes sense because what they
noticed is Yes. which what they notice
is you know they want to allow people
the freedom to create their own training
loops their own tensor operation like
custom tensor operations but a lot of
times people write slow code so what
they did do theyite do they decide to do
they are like oh let's write some a
compiler that takes that slow code and
makes it faster right that's kind of
their approach your approach is let us
handle it um like well compile doesn't
work like it doesn't even make
because our networks are small.
Yes. And I I'm not again I'm not saying
this is something that Puffer Lip does
bad. I'm just observing how like I'm
just giving an observation of how
PyTorch handled basically a very similar
issue here. Um and I think it's okay. I
think what you're doing is okay where
you abstract this thing but I think
it'll be good uh so go back to that kind
of uh simple example
uh
like that simple example you had the
example.py pie or whatever uh you
had. Yeah. What I think you should do is
like for example like kind of explain
like we um give this kind of higher
level evaluate and train API because of
a lot of performance optimizations we do
for you kind of thing you know like a
low comment uh for each of them. It's
annoying because like this thing here, I
don't like that this takes away the your
access to the environment, right? Like
in my mind, your you should have access
to the environment, which is the
stepping here. But the thing is the main
point of this file, if you want to do
stuff with it, it isn't for you to call
this function. It's to copy this
freaking script and edit it.
Mhm. I see. Because like I like I can't
if I give you access to this function.
If I give you access to here, if I give
you access to mstepping,
which is the receive function and the
send function. First of all, do you know
how obnoxious it is to get this loop
right? You have to call receive. Yes. At
the start and then you have to call send
at the bottom. Oh, where's send? at the
bottom here. Let's see. Yes. Okay. Okay.
And receive is receiving uh rewards and
send or observations and send um sends
an action kind of in. Yeah. Okay. Okay.
And then like but like look at all the
stuff that there is in the middle of
this. Yeah. So right here I see
basically this is the pietorch level of
puffer lib. Yes. So this is the code
that you're intended to see. Yes. And
like the thing is when you go back to
here, when you go to here, it's like,
yeah, you've abstracted it too much.
This isn't the level you're supposed to
be at, though. Like you're supposed to
be here, which is why I was just
providing this damn thing as a script. I
Okay, I get that point. Um, but first of
all, I want to send a quick observation.
So what would So the PyTorch thing to do
here would be to go to the top of the
function and have the at compile like
you know what I mean like the um
basically let people write the function
and then compile it. But the thing is
like put like an at compile you know
like make a a wrapper like an at compile
wrapper where um people kind of have
like a very basic for loop and you add
you kind of metro program all the
complication into it. That would
probably be the PyTorch way to do it but
it doesn't work.
Yes, exactly. It doesn't work currently.
Like you see like they have a a full
team of like geniuses on it and they
still are struggling with it. Like we
have we we try compile like in most
cases compile makes most of our training
slower. I'm not even joking. And like
honestly like there all these RL people
that are like oh yeah we got like 6x
speed up with compile. Yeah cuz you
started at a thousand steps per second
because your initial starting code was
terrible right.
Yeah I I yeah I I get what you're
saying. But that's the thing. So yes, I
agree with you that as a let's say as
like a serious RL developer or
researcher or engineer, whatever you
want to call it, it will go and use and
basically copy the evaluate function and
use it, right? And like modify it to
their own, right? Yeah. Like what you
would do is like the thing is if you're
ser if you're actively a researcher, the
intent is still that you clone the repo
and you mess with stuff. Like I think
that the thing is that like if you want
to contribute an envo for
instance, you can
totally just like use the pufferell
script. But then like my question is if
I give you
this like if I give you this versus if I
give you puffer what are you learning?
So from this I okay so all the logic is
hidden from you still right like all the
structure I think the structure um is
still there and what you can do is
so the the main kind of validations of
um abstraction I see here is the
evaluate and train right
those are like the main kind of um you
can say like well our vectorzation
abracted. Yeah, that's not that's not
overly abstracted. That's just freaking
hard. Yeah, but that's not overly
Exactly. Um, so what I think I think is
again this is not um you know when you
give someone a PyTorch notebook of like
a um of like a simple kind of like I
don't know like a MLP, right? you don't
expect them to um use that to develop
the uh you know machine learning and
take it further right like this is what
we're providing in some sense is like
this
working loop I so so yeah so what I'm
saying is the the kind of the point of
bringing that example is kind of like a
very brief introduction of how uh the
puffer lib
code is structured in the sense of like
we first get the arguments then we train
it on these arguments and we then we log
it then we do this right so like you
have here if you take a look you see how
you have the structure of we're creating
an environment with end creator then
we're take we're getting args then we're
vectorizing those environments then
we're initializing the policy um then
like you have the structure so kind of
my point with like the initial kind kind
of um thing for puffer lib is the
structure. You want the user to first
just understand the structure and then
once they kind of understand this you
kind of try to encourage them or kind of
uh like let's say in the next example
you then say okay you are the evaluate
and train this is like how you actually
make like how you actually um use the
library. Do you want people not do you
want just people to read this or do you
want people to actually use this? I want
people to read and experiment with
experiment with this to get started, not
to use this in production.
Okay. So, like in Yeah. Does that make
sense?
I'm trying to think where and how I do
this cuz like I don't hate the
suggestion of take Neptune out and I
don't hate the suggestion of like take
the um some of the like the config
loading stuff out. That's fine.
And I I do agree with you though that
like I would love to have a un um un uh
hidden like unhidden evaluated like the
the unhidden is this code.
Yeah, it's the entrance. Yeah, it's
genuinely it's this full file. And like
the thing is you see a thousand line
file and you go, "Oh, how do I like like
how do I simplify this?" But this
thousandline file does what normally you
would need 20,000 lines for, right? Yes.
But I I guess it's not everything like
what am I hiding from you here? So
technically you don't have sweeps in
here. So this is another file. This is a
relatively short file actually. We're
going to cut like 150 lines of code off
of this before release at least. It'll
be sub uh sub 500 lines. Okay. And like
this will be so you'll get to see this
and you have like a 100ish lines of code
here. And this is pretty much the
algorithm.
It's all math, right? And then I'm
hiding from you. I'm hiding from you. I
guess our our default model, but it's
really just a pietorch model. like we
have this little tiny thing that we do
with encode decode to make LSTMs easier,
but other than that it's really just
like a basic ass pietorch model, right?
And then like I'm not really hiding
anything else. Like that's genuinely all
the code, right? And I and I agree, but
I think so I agree that this code is
perfectly good to kind of as an to serve
as an example for a user who wants to
use this for research or for whatever
else or like industry tasks, right?
Yeah. I think for like a researcher like
this, if I'm a researcher, this is what
I want to be handed, right? So I guess
it's like so when at least for me well
I'm that's the thing I'm not really a
researcher so I'm coming from the
perspective of um like a software
engineer or someone who like created um
ML stuff and RL stuff like from scratch
like some simple things but then when I
get handed that my first problem is not
the implementation details it's the
structure I don't know what gets called
before what and like the structure of
what gets called and that's kind of the
main thing that that example pie kind of
shows me help me understand then help me
understand this right so like you have
something that's very similar to this if
I just remove the argument parse yes so
if I just go to like puffer lib clean
pufferl
and I go to
like let's say that this function starts
this function starts here okay so you
see you have the end creator
You have the policy class. There's still
a little bit of fluff here, right? Not
that much. Um, and then you have sweep
code.
Where's sweep code? Oh, yeah. I see.
It's a little gross now because this
args is not my uh my syntax highlighting
is not picking this up. Yeah, you have
this is your sweep stuff and you have
like where's train? Train just calls
experiment. I guess this code would be
you see you have like a lot of like if
train if if sweep. What would you want
it to look like? I would want it to have
just an example that just trains. It
doesn't check if I'm I'm going to be
training or I'm going to be eval I just
want to train something. What is the
order of functions I'm calling to make
that happen? So what do I call first?
Then what do I call like before doing
this? Does it suffice? So I guess
technically the only reason I can't put
train at the top is because I want to be
able to load default policies in. Um
I guess the the one question I have is
like so like if you're trying to do this
to like if you're trying to use this to
learn stuff or to like get your ends
working and you want the high the highle
interface is like is like this, right?
So like torch.py or here. So let's call
this is like torch.py and then this is
like from
puffer
lib.models import
default as policy or if you want you can
do class my policy like
nn.module you know whatever
super
self.mlp you know dotted dot whatever it
is. So you make like your little net and
then like you have like your
m.py and you do so this is your your
thing that you're making now you do like
class my m and this is like puffer
lib.puffer m and then definite like and
you do you know your stuff here and then
I and then I can also give you like you
know config.in any and you do like this
yada yada and thenel
uh
en like my
env like you could do this. I could give
you this interface as a newcomer.
So you have okay and I could just give
you this. So this is all you need.
So you just write your net, you write
your end, and you write a config, and
you call puffarel, and then you don't
have to deal with this file at all. I
could do
that. Well, what? Okay. Okay. So, I
guess maybe it's better to explain like
the problem I was having when I first
kind of started and it was mostly and
kind of like let you maybe like problem
solve it yourself. But my first problem
was how things are kind of structured in
the sense of like what like what comes
after the other. So like
um does that make sense? kind of like
what's kind of the problem execution
graph. That's the problem I have with
every freaking codebase. Um I've seen
some really really nasty ones. Um yeah,
for sure. And like there's a little bit
of branching in Puffer, which is why
like
I guess even the experiment function is
slightly annoying. I have that there
because I reuse it with sweeps. Um
I think that's the only thing that gets
called though. I think it goes if train
experiment which then makes clean puff
RL and like does this code.
Mhm. Um well what what yeah kind of I
guess what I'm saying is like the first
thing that would really help at least
for me as a newcomer as like a a
newcomer to like puffer lib was um if I
had something like
well I care about I care about what gets
called after what because then I can go
into the puffer uh like RL file and be
like okay like I kind of have a mental
model of like okay this is the function
that gets called after this one uh and
it takes and it messes with this data
this function get then gets does that
make sense is this for the purpose of
getting your M to work or is this for
the purpose of like trying to understand
how the RL code is working how those are
two different yes like if you just want
your M to work if you just want your M
to work I give you this you don't have
to open clean puffel at all and your and
will work right that's not what I'm
talking about I'm talking about
understand I'm talking about kind of
like as a um so as a step to reading
clean uh or like pufferl right that's
kind of what I'm so the thing okay so I
so basically it's just as hard as I have
worked to make this thing simpler it
just ain't simple enough yet so like no
no it's simple that's fair and like I
could make like I could probably
restructure Here let's let's actually
let me this will be useful if I give you
this. Have you read clean RL?
Uh not much. Okay. So this is the gold
standard for simple RL like Costa
is like my pick for goat of re like the
goat of reinforcement learning. He is
awesome. Okay. Um so this is PO on Atari
286 lines. Mhm.
He does use these are just rappers.
These are just reward rappers. So
there's no other dependencies. No, this
is just torch. There's no like other
fancy things in cleaner. It's a single
file. Yeah. Arguments. Yeah, that's that
that looks nice. Yeah, that that looks
good. Make an all hardcoded in one file.
Mhm. Okay, here's your agent.
Yep. Okay, this is Yes. This is what you
want, right? Um let me see the args. Oh.
Oh, those are like kind of arc wrapper
you can see. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. And you
have the main function. And then yeah,
this this Yeah, this is kind of what I
want. Not because um well well this is
what everyone wants. This is what you
want because this is fantastic code.
Costa writes amazing stuff. So and this
is the this is the train loop right
here.
He's got he has actually a lot of the
features. He's got a kneeling learning
rate, right? He's got everything
here. Okay. And then he even has he's
got generalized advantage estimation in
here.
He's got the whole train loop. It's
almost what we have.
We actually this code is copied in our
puffer lib is copied directly from him.
Like this. He has a lot of it here. But
here's the thing with here's the thing
that gets tough, right? So first of all,
you cannot use this code to evaluate
your policy. This is a combined train
and eval loop.
So as soon as you split that apart, as
soon as you split those two things
apart, now you need to share the entire
global state of this program between two
separate functions. Okay. So then that's
where that's why there's a class clean
puffl. It's because you have to go back
and forth between train and eval. There
are some other reasons, but that's the
biggest one. Okay. So then and then on
top of that, so this doesn't have sweep
integration at all. Sweeps is not that
hard. It just like it's a for loop that
has to run on top of your code, which is
another reason you can't just have
everything as globals as globals. Um,
and then this has gymnasium synchronous
vector end, which makes the data storage
format a fair bit simpler than ours is
at the price of it being way slower.
Yes. Okay. Uh and I when I say
synchronous like even gym vector async
vector m it's not asynchronous in the
way that RMS are like it's different. Um
okay. So we get that. Now he goes
through these evals. Um he is not doing
any sort of performance profiling on any
of this. So you're missing all of that.
No logging. Yeah there's no logging
here. There is logging of like losses
but this is not like sufficient right
but we have to do that for sure. Uh we
have profiling loggings too. Yeah. So we
have profiling of like your hardware
utilization first of all and then we
also have profiling of all the M stats
and we also have our local dashboard
printout so you're not locked to wandi
for all your visualizations. You
actually get them in your Okay. So we
have that. Um, we support AM, we support
compile, we support distributed
training, we have all of those. Okay.
Oh, okay. So, we have all that. We also
are the way that we run our mini
batching is not the same as Clean RL
does because we have uh advantage
filtering. Okay. We have gradient
accumulation. We have all these
additional features. Right. Right. Okay.
And then the big one, right, is the fact
that like from the CLI you get to
choose. You can run training, you can
run sweeps, you can run eval, right? You
can you have a bunch of different
options of things that you can run. Um,
and also we don't have a single end
hardcoded like this. You can run from
the command line any envir.
Uh, it can load whatever config file for
that specific end. Right. So like
exactly what we did here. I my goal here
and everyone tries to do this and fails
because cost is just a genius and it's
like as soon as you try to do cleaner
but like cleaner but more features
everyone hard falls on their face and
I've just done my best right so like
what I try to do is keep it as damn
simple as I possibly can while making it
fast and having like the minimal set of
features that you would want to be able
to do research. Yes. The the thing is
like yours my problem is not that puffer
RL file like the puffer RL script is not
simple enough in terms of the core
logic. My problem is that it has a lot
of the fluff that this doesn't have.
That's kind of the main difference I see
between uh this PO Atari and the Puffer
Rel. This is all hardcoded. Right. Um
it's all hardcoded. Yeah. And yours is
all dynamic, which then takes away from
like it it kind of you can think of it
as like it that complexity takes the
stage away from the actual meat of what
puffer lib does, which is not argument
parsing, not fancy config uh
evaluations. It's good performant
reinforcement learning. Yeah. And now
the issue is that as if I hardcode it,
you can't use the thing because like you
our our pipeline, right? Like our
research loop is not we just run one
environment for a month, right? Like the
research loop is we use multiple
environments with multiple different
policies and we run experiments,
hundreds of experiments on these to make
sure that what we're doing is actually
sensible. So like if I hard code it,
it's like immediately useless, which is
tough. What what I'm saying is that
hardcoded is not that hard-coded version
of puffer RL is not meant to be used for
actual good experiments. It's meant it's
meant for documentation so people and
when they start out can read it and not
be like uh and not follow bunch of like
fancy config and argument parts. So I
would cut out like I could cut I think
if I cut everything everything that's
like dynamically done I think you only
cut 100 lines
and that's and that's fine at least for
me because um so having a whole separate
file that isn't actually useful but to
cut 100 lines out of 900 so so again it
would be
um it would be more
like so it would be more of like a
documentation file. It would be like an
example MD or something like that. But
then again, then you have like a let me
let me do this another way here. Like so
there's no stuff is not jank. When you
get to clean puffer, is stuff still jank
or is stuff jank in the main function?
It's mostly in the main function. Okay.
Kind of biggest issue. Okay. So if I
just take this main function for you,
right? And I give you the version of
this where like I said I split out all
the loading stuff and then when you're
actually reading this logic it's not
module name import lib it's just like
you know env or it's policy or whatever.
Yes. Does that do it? That would be at
least for me as like a first-time reader
would be way clearer. Okay. Um cuz then
I would be like cuz as a reader I'll be
like okay so it goes when does it go to
if sweep? Okay. Hey, I have to look at
the arg mode and then you know what I
mean? So then do you want this to be do
you want this function to then be
shorter? So does this does this go in a
method for you? Do I make a sweep method
here? And then
so what I'm saying is more like you know
how you have like basically this main
handles training uh like it handles all
the different uh arguments with those
like if else if and all that kind of
thing. What I want as like at least for
documentation and reading not as like a
well you can still use it. I can just I
can split these things out and they
don't have to like I can split these
things out with arcs. Like I actually
had it that way at some point. So
So okay. Well, what I mean
is like you know how uh clean RL doesn't
worry about it being uh like handling
all these different like sweep like it
it doesn't have if sweep if train if
eval. It just eval trains, right? Like
it it does the train loop and then like
it does the eval right in all one kind
of thing. But you Yes, you do. But you
kind of have like uh so you see how you
have like if args mode profile which I'm
guessing is for like extra performance.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So this kind of
stuff the clean RL doesn't have which
makes it easier to read but less useful
right. Yeah like I can give you
what I want is something is an example
that is not as useful but is easier to
read if that makes sense. What about
this? If you look at this code
yes that looks good. That looks uh well
if again now you have the eval and train
right that would be um I'm guessing
those functions above it you have it
yeah the eval and train yeah that looks
to be honest if I got something like
this and then above it like you said
like you initialize the um environment
you vectorize it you get so you want you
want to see the initializations here as
well I want I want to see the um the
environment Oh, oh yeah. Oh, yeah. You
have the vecend, right? Yeah. Cuz yeah,
I do want to see it because as let's say
a user, I'll be like, "Oh, uh, vecend is
easily created by just, you know, giving
it uh my environment kind of thing. I
can kind of create environment and I can
I mean, basically all this comes all
this comes down to right is that the
loading and like the dynamic loading
logic is confusing.
It's it's it's not it's it's not
confusing. It's understandable. It's
It's perfectly
understandable as a first time reader.
It distracts from the main points of
this file. So like,
and I'm talking from purely reading
perspective, not functionality.
So I'm trying to think then what I So
like, okay, I could
take It's tough because if you just
don't read this, right? If you just
don't read here, if you start reading
here, Yeah. you're good, right? Or
basically, yeah. Well, I guess you want
you want this stuff. Hang on. You want
this stuff. Let's say I get let's say I
take all this dynamic stuff and I put
this I leave the dynamic stuff in main.
I leave the branching stuff in main.
Yes.
And then like let's say that I pass
you. Let's say I pass args. I pass like
anything that had to be done
dynamically. Like let's say that I pass
you instead of passing you the vechen,
right? Let's say I pass you args and I
pass you the vechen class. No, that
still [ __ ] doesn't work because now
it's a dynamic class. God damn it. So,
so I guess kind of what I'm trying to
get at is you're trying to write
something that's as readable as um clean
rail like the cleaner rail PO but with
more functionality and more uh and more
and nonrelated RL function. So, I guess
here's the difficult thing, right? If
for documentation purposes I make a
version of this that's like just
everything hardcoded, I have to maintain
both of them. Right. Right. Do you know
how do you know how what a pain it is
for clean RL? Look, this is how much
stuff they have to change every time
they change like they change their
argument parsing. These are all the
scripts they have to update. Yes. Yes.
Right. You see this refactor to use
Tyro.
So I have to do this every time I change
an N which is like fine. Yes. But when
you're changing the the train scripts
themselves, like getting stuff
consistent across that train script is
way sketchier. Like that's tough. Um
it's really easy to mess stuff up in
that.
Okay. So like and the thing is these are
actually intended to be used as well. So
they don't just maintain these for docs
really like these are like you use
these. So the idea for researchers,
right? If you're a researcher, this is
how clean works. You you take this file,
you copy this file, you paste in
whatever your variables and your N and
now you do your research.
Yes. Okay. Right. Now the assumption
there, right, is that you're not running
sweeps. You're using a single
environment.
Yeah. Which is frankly a lot of the
reason that RL sucks is because that's
how people were doing research for a
decade.
Okay.
So, you know how he kind of has it is is
he has it as a not as a uh um CLI tool.
He has like a statically set in file
tool if that kind of makes sense. Well,
this also gives you this also gives you
CLI, I believe, because Tyro does that
for you. I believe Tyro does that for
you. It's the same as Argar. I didn't
want to use Tyro because it's just an
external DEP, right? Argar is a built
in.
Oh, okay. Yeah. Okay. Um, there are
millions of that. Does he have config
files? No, he has this because these are
all of his arguments. He doesn't have
sweeps and he has like a quarter of our
number of arguments. Uhhuh. Now that I
think about it, why have both arguments
and a config file?
Yeah. So, that's what I was saying is
that I could if it was easier, I could
put all these into a config file. Now
it's a little bit silly because then
it's like you know I have hardcoded like
my project I guess in a con file and
stuff like I guess it's fine. I guess I
can do that.
I think I think it'll be well I think
it'll be cleaner to read as well. Like I
think it'll be much cleaner to read. Um
okay I can take all of these.
The only thing is there's like the one
other thing that arg gives you. It gives
you like these choices things. But like
this will tell you invalid choice or
whatever if I give you this. So like I
could take out but here I could take out
realistically but then everything except
what if let's say I take out everything
that doesn't have choices. So I I give
you render mode and I give you like mode
but I like I give you these and then
everything else I take out or I could
just manually validate either way. So
you know what you I think I think what
taking all it t basically putting all
the arc parse arguments into the config
file will also do is it'll allow you to
abstract away the config reading uh like
like basically reading and parsing all
out of the main function. Right now it's
tied to it. Well I can put this in a
separate function. I can so this code
right from here down to here I can just
take all this and put it in a separate
function
right it doesn't have to be in main yes
but the thing is let's say let's say I
take all these arguments out okay you
still have this code you will still have
all this code
yes that that I think is fine because um
if you let's say here look at my screen
um it'll be um like you still have that
code but let's say um I for example um
wanted to do kind of my import thing
where I have like import example like
from example let's say import example
and then what I would have is let's say
I would do like config and I would do
like uh um example.load
load load uh config right and then I
would give my path uh and then I would
have uh kind of my uh I would have the
example main which takes the or this
actually will be the args and that would
just take the args does that make sense
kind of this is the function that
abstracts all the kind of dynamic
loading what does this do nastiness away
what when you literally when you
literally have like a twoline thing,
what does this do for you over uh the
current script?
Well, uh it for me, so having something
like this instead of having just uh main
like this where um I know of main is uh
main has everything. it um it doesn't do
something functional uh like
functionally. It does something
um it does something in my head where it
kind of allows me to kind of have that
split of like this is where um the
actual meat of the code starts and this
if I want to look at the config stuff I
can jump to this
function and look at it right I can jump
to that example
and look at it well like there's still a
bajillion things I have to do to load
here right because like I need your end
I need
Yeah. And you have still that like it's
tough and like I also have to make the
CLI tool work. You you have these stuff,
right? You have these stuff. So like
this thing I can make it I guess I can
give you an interface that works this
way. But like I'm still also going to
need to have a thing where like if you
call puffer like let's say you use a
CLI, right, and you do like pufferl
train, it still is going to have to look
it's going to have to look in your
current directory anyways for configs
and for ends.
Yeah, you have all these like Yeah. Um,
so yeah.
Um,
so okay. So I
guess what
um, so let's say um, we removed all
these arc
bars.
Um, we basically said, you know what, we
don't have this. We don't need this. We
just have Well, you need the you need
the ar you need the the actual
initialization of our car still. We just
need this. We just need this. What? No,
you need you need the ar you need um you
can delete all the add argument lines.
This one. This one. Yeah, you can delete
all the so except you deleted the last
one as well. Except that one. Oh, oops.
Yeah, you can delete all but that. Yeah.
Okay. So, we can have it I we can
shorten it to that. Yes. But my question
is first of all
um you you need that why because you
then um use it here for um well then you
just can't run anything from CLI
otherwise like when you do d- your end
name you just can't do that. Oh, right,
right. You need you need it for just
having like overriding arcs
um over there needs to be something that
parses like CLI arguments like train
script arguments.
Do you still want to have like um like a
C allow allow write um overwriting CLI
like a config arguments with the CLI
because literally everyone uses it that
way and like people go crazy if you make
them do everything just in config files.
Okay, I see what you mean because then
every time you want to change like to
train versus eval or like like whatever
like you have to go edit a mode flag
inside of a config file. So people like
having CLI. Now the thing is some people
like lots of CLI flags. Some some people
will be like d-train total time steps
equals this d-gamy. Like some people
literally do everything from CLI and
like some people will do most of the
stuff in a config file. But like
everybody uses at least a little bit of
CLI like you have to have the arcs.
Now I don't have to have them in here,
right? They don't have to be in here
necessarily because all I have to do is
I can delete those and then just be like
you know run dash like dynamic. I can
just put a comment dynamically
populated. Run d-help for a full list of
arguments.
Oh yeah, that's actually cool. But okay,
that okay. Um Okay. Yeah, that that's
a that sounds actually good.
Um but I guess it still doesn't kind of
solve the main kind of problem that we
are bouncing between. No, that just
deletes 20. It just deletes 20 lines of
arguments. That's all. Yeah, it yeah, it
deletes 21 lines. Yeah, it's Yeah,
exactly.
Um, so the main difficulty here I see is
like having kind of like a simplified
um static version of this file would
would basically add maintenance cost.
Um, and it will not serve functionally.
It will only serve documentarily if that
makes sense. which means that um well
you have to maintain something that is
only served for um that's not useful. I
guess it's like you can run I guess like
I can give you
I mean let me think is that even
hard I just do it. What if Okay. Oh, you
know what you can do is instead of
having to like okay um I copy this, I
copy that, like like let's say I was
like, okay, I'm gonna copy like because
what you're going to do is you're
basically going to take this file and
you're going to remove uh these stuff,
right? Like all of these stuff. Um and
then you're going to remove uh a lot of
the weird importing things and replace
them with static imports. Um, and
basically you're just going to be
changing. It doesn't make sense to me to
copy the entire file though, right?
You're saying like you want to reuse
them so you don't have to maintain two
exactly equal functions. I don't see the
point in giving this is like a this is
an 800 something line fun uh file,
right? But like I I don't see the if I'm
going to give you of actual code, it's
800 and something. Yeah. So like if I
give you I it doesn't make a huge
difference to me if I give you an 800
line function with some config loading
or an 800 line function that is
statically coded like in terms of
complexity like if you want to
understand this file the complexity
difference is not that big at least I
could be wrong like right but like in my
head it's not that big. The thing that
does make sense is if like if I give you
something like this, right, where it's
like, okay, I'm importing that file and
I'm giving you 50 lines of code. Yeah.
Like I that I can jam and then the
question is like, okay, do you want your
three files that just calls this call
the script with do you want you
basically want like an experiment? I
like I like that first one like where
you just have that single file with it
is over abstracted but I think it it its
main point is to show you just want to
see where our main API pieces like or
our main like calls. Okay, cool. Yeah, I
can I can probably do something for that
and then like I I you know honestly I
would it would be nice if I didn't even
have to have this in the repo and I
could just put this on the docs page. So
like yes exactly and then what you can
do is you can copy I can make it
runnable you can just copy paste and you
can run it right
and that gives you a basic end to end
like whip install puffer lib and then
take that copy paste run it you're good
well we don't want you to think this is
the main interface though right yes yes
but this is like a good kind of like how
um I got to give you both I gotta give
you this. So I have to give you like
pufferell and how you use it from the
CLI. Okay. I have to give you then I
have to give you this thing where I give
you like a little demo like this. Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Obviously it'll be like it'll be more
full than this. Like it will be an
actually working and of an actually
working policy. So this will probably be
like I can get this down to like a 100
lines, right?
So, and then I give you a 100 lines and
then this is like how you write a sample
project,
right?
Okay.
Um, and actually this is pretty easy
because I can like copy in like squared
or I can copy in like an existing end
here.
Um, okay. So we can do that and
then let me
think I give you this
that and then we still have the main RL
stuff but in the process of giving you
this file. So in the process of giving
you this I will probably split out or at
least change some of the signatures to
things. Let me see. Is that
true? Well, this is not real
code. Let me see. Let me see what calls
what at this
point. So, experiment takes vec policy
and arcs.
So, yeah, I would basically just give
you that file that we were like
workshopping.
So if I give you this like example.py in
demo is this useful if I just give you
if I give you something like this.
Um yes like that that would be useful at
least when I first saw the library if I
saw that I'll be like it'll be easier
for me um to kind of understand the
whole kind of data flow of buffer lib.
Now, I think you're still you're still
going to be confused, though, because
you're going to paste this in. You're
going to be like, "Okay, cool. That
works." And then you're going to open
this file and be like, "What the hell?"
Um, yeah. And like to be fair, there are
a few reasons that you're going to be
like, "What the hell?" One of them is
just that it's like 8 900 lines of code,
which is like, "Yeah, it's 8 900 lines,
but it does what like normally would
take tens of thousands." So, that's kind
of fine. But then the other thing is
like I kind of have all this args
dynamic stuff mixed in, right? So like I
guess if
I the thing is I hate having tons and
tons of like little shitty functions
that don't do much. Yeah. So so you know
what you can do is just uh section out
all those dynamicy things. Just create
like a big comment saying like um
dynamic uh argument handling and then
people can be like oh we can skip that.
You know I have these things here right
like I have these sectioned off.
Well, yes, but I think having something
that's more like um you know how
sometimes a good um kind of a sectioner
of code that I really like is a guy from
a community called Handmade.
Um his name I think it was like his name
was uh like fourth coder or something
like that. um for
coder. Let me see. But he um comments
his code very nicely. Um and he uses
like he he mostly works in C and he has
like long functions but they're just
commented very well. Mr. Forth. Yeah,
that's kind of like his thing. Uh Mr.
Forth. Yeah, let me see. Uh I'll show
you some like a bit like 1 C file or
something like that. Uh let's say for
coder it's one of his things he created.
Uh let's look at like oh has a GitHub
where's the
GitHub builtin command
documentation. Where's
the performance? Let's see. Okay.
uh for coder let's say
okay where's the
code I think it
was oh here it
is get
yes uh
explore yeah let's look for example
at this
source. Let's look at the C file. So,
you see he like it's a little slow, but
he has like comments like this where
this is all of his functions.
Um, this is like his
tests like uh and he kind of
like sections them like out like and
that's the thing though like with your
if you take a look at that's funny cuz I
really don't like that comment style
really. Yeah. I don't know. I I I
Maybe it's just that it's weirdly like
just a comment that just says functions
is kind of dumb, right? Yeah, I agree
with that. I agree with that. Um but
what I mean is more like um like you
have a comment that says distribution
and then you have a function that's just
named distribution under it. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
I it's I guess meant for like like all
these functions are distribute are
related to distribution but they're
literally all prefix distribution.
Yeah, exactly. Um so like
I agree. Um, it's kind of like pick one,
right? Yeah. Yeah, makes sense. I get
what you're saying. Um, but I guess
I No, I I definitely So like I can but
if like ultimately so like I I almost
don't think it's enough to just stick a
comment there because like you know the
code is there and it's like you have to
deal with like it at some like I could
just like split this. The thing is I I
sort of thought about it and it's
like is it worth splitting this like now
you have like argu like arg main or cli
main or like whatever right and then you
have another layer of function calls as
a
result. So if it's worth the other layer
which I guess is what I'm hearing is it
kind of is cuz like the dynamic stuff is
really a pain in the ass to read. Um it
it's it's not pain in the ass. it just
uh kind of like takes the spotlight like
not just and I'm not talking about just
this. I'm talking about um
the little stuff like this stuff like
like even even I mean yeah that stuff is
whatever actually this is not that hard
to be honest. I think the kind of things
that confuse me at first is stuff like
this is stuff like this. I wonder if I
can give you
like what's you know what maybe I Yeah,
that's that's a torch distributed stuff.
Um maybe what I can do
I have an idea. I might No promises. I
don't know how hard this is to do, but I
might be able to do it so that I just
have a function that is I guess train is
already taken, but like yeah, a train
function, a sweep function, whatever.
not inside of main and then I just give
you entry points to those
but then you can't call it as a script
which is a little shitty.
[Music]
Uh it's that's kind of what do you mean
you can't call it as a script? You can.
So you wouldn't be able to do like
Python
um right
Python clean. No, you could do import
train. You could still import, but you
wouldn't be able to call this Python
like what would you do is you'd have to
call pufferl from the command line which
is like I would be able to get rid of
all this logic though.
I think
so. Why do why do you think you wouldn't
be able to um have train and all that
stuff be importable? I guess so. Let me
let me show you let me show you what I'm
I'm thinking here. So, do you know what
entry points are, right? Uh yes. Okay.
So, like Yeah. So, like look if I do
this. Let me get some space
here. All right. So, we can do like
death sweep. Now, this is the sketchy
thing cuz it has to be like this. Yeah.
And then we do well we can do we can do
like puffer swip or sweep or something
there you know like okay so this is this
is going to be clean this is clean puff
forel.py okay right okay so
then uh this is sweep okay uh and like
all this will be in clean puffer here
there you know we give you a big block
yeah there have there happy now this is
going to be to call this function you do
this you do pufferl
sweep n my n um and like
Ah, I see. So instead of having it as
another CLI uh arg have it as an entry
point. Yeah. So I can do this like back
end. Okay.
So what I was I can do like this and
then I can do like
you can have different entry points,
right? Yeah. So I can do this and then I
can do like deaf train and then this is
just like it's going to have like a very
similar block and then it'll do like
this and then like the thing it's a
little tricky cuz like you know I have
to make some shared things for this. So
there still has to be a few other things
but then like I don't need to have there
just wouldn't be a main at all. if
statements. Yeah, there won't be a I
guess I technically could. So I could
technically do if name is I could still
do like the higher level thing. So I
could do like load configs and then or
not even this. I could just do like this
if right I could just do like this. So I
guess I could technically Oops. I really
like this actually. I really like this
suggestion. So I could just do that. It
sounds you know what I think would be
cool. So yeah,
since so you know how um you know Python
has like a um an even defaulter um
argument
parsing thing if I recall. Wait, wait,
wait. Let me just congratulate Tyler.
Hey yo, Tyler, congrats on uh
congratulations, man.
Nice,
nice job. Wow. Well, he's doing better
than me. All right. Um, but yeah, that's
that looks really good. Um, yeah, that
I'm I'm not gonna lie, that looks like
really good. And then you can actually
Yes, you can have um so the parse args
will include will basically if you um so
like you know how you have here parse
args and then you have vecan load
vehals parse args and parse args will
return. Um, so this is the thing. If you
call these, if you call these from C,
like if you call these from like you
import them,
they don't have any damn arguments. So,
right. So, you can Yes. Okay. But what
you can do is I can still give you I
would still be able to give you, you
know,
example.py. Okay. And then I basically
just give you this code,
right?
Okay. I just give you the train function
basically because that's all it is.
That's all you want.
Yes.
But I think I have something like I have
I think I have an idea. So you know how
you have like the um let's look at the
like for example the def train um quot
um parenthesis and you have the parse
args um that that function. Yeah that
entry point. So
um that entry point
my question is so this is like oops
actually let me Google like this
I can't even believe I'm looking at this
because like this is the way like the
like all the big libraries do stuff and
it sucks but I like I think it's it
sucks so hard but I think that that I
think that it's kind of okay in our case
because the thing is what you're calling
is just like a function in a single file
script. Like the thing that makes it bad
in their case is that like you're
calling an unreachable blob of code that
you will never be able to find anywhere.
Like all may as well not exist and like
links into 50 other files.
Actually, um Oh yeah, Tyler, don't
listen to me by the way. Like my like my
negativity towards academia
is probably very heavily inspired by CS
in particular. Like posttock and CS
versus posttock and physics are two very
different things cuz in CS like you just
need a laptop to do stuff. So like you
may as well go do anything other than be
stuck to a university where their
resources don't matter for [ __ ] But
like you know in physics there's actual
equipment and stuff. So like it it's
very just very very different worlds and
they also pay you very little. Well
that's true everywhere in postocs.
Yeah. Um they pay you uh they pay you I
think it's uh I it's like half a
professor salary. Wow.
But like they require you to like
relocate as well. But like the thing is
the professor salaries are already like
a fifth of what they would be in
industry. Yeah. So like you could be
making you could be making like 80k as a
posttock but like you would be making
you know 1.2 million in industry.
I I can't imagine making that much
money. Jesus that's that is market rate
for uh that is market rate for like good
AI people these days. So that's insane.
But um I guess my question right now
which I'm I guess I'm trying to test is
um
python let's let's say I have my
example 2.py pie and what you basically
have is basically puffer RL is basically
just this right and then you can have
entry points of like um entry one right
that's kind of what you're saying
uh no um and I see let's see where's the
example where's the example
example so what you're doing here is if
I go to main. You're just calling the
main function. But then how would you do
I guess um the entry the different entry
points that's uh entry points are
defined here. Entry points are defined
in setup. The entry points are defined
in setup.py and setup.py. The functions
are defined here. The functions are
defined here. The thing that links them
to a command is the setup.py.
Ah right. Right. because which is
literally it just is like you know it's
just like tougher like trainer like it's
just the name of the thing. So yes. Um
and then you have entry. Okay.
And so what I'm I kind of am asking is
for those entry points um like
this and you have
um and you have stuff like args equals I
don't know like empty like this and then
ars args um and then you can give it the
let's say it's the w args and then you
have
W args like this. Um I can you and you
like if this is possible then that means
you can have best of both worlds. You
can call it from the CLI and you can
then just in a different file import
entry one or whatever like entry point
specification. I will I will see. Yeah.
Hey Tyler, if you've got cool RL stuff,
we are uh we are expanding things and we
are definitely we want to be doing more
RL on hard tech and not just purely
games. We like games as a test bed for
our own internal stuff, but we want to
be doing more RL on hard tech
and and especially I bet making it like
a business like actually a legitimate
business because then you can have
funding to actually pay. Puffer is a
legitimate business. Yeah, Puffer is No.
Well, yeah, but like I I have more
revenue, you know. Yeah, we always
revenue. Oh, yeah. increasing revenue
was always uh I mean you know the
servers the servers aren't cheap. We
just bought uh we just bought two tiny
boxes and then whenever some prices come
down a bit we ideally are going to buy
20 30 40 desktops depending Oh
and they're like as soon as they're
quoting us not seven grand a desktop.
Yeah. But what I guess what I'm trying
to say is like um if Puffer like
actually has like substantial revenue
um or even like kind of if he like
basically becomes like a like the
research lab for RL that would be
amazing. That's what we're trying to do.
And I like we are doing it to be fair at
the moment. Like literally RL is a
different field than it was a year ago
right now because of puffer and it's
like nobody has remotely done come close
to doing these things like cuz nobody
was willing to sit down and write 30,000
lines of C.
Yeah. Imagine if you would have had
instead of just like unemployed people
like me like trying to contribute and
help um have like actual like be able to
hire like actual researchers. I don't
actually know how much better I don't
even know how much better it is to be
honest because like the open source
people are just are the most motivated
ones anyways. Like a lot of the MS have
come from uh from open source
contributors and I mean we are starting
to do stuff now. I mean I I don't like
to advertise this because it's like it's
trying to entice people to do free work
with the potential promise of payment.
So I like to keep it more it's just open
source work but we are starting to like
pull like contributors and stuff into
contracts. Um so like that is a thing. I
don't advertise that upfront because
it's like it's you know it's you know do
work with the potential of being paid is
kind of scummy but like that is
ultimately what I want to be able to do
is to be able to like you know have the
talent funnel come from our open source
contributors because hiring an AI sucks
like think about it if you're going to
pay people market rate for AI which is
very high and it's like it's not even
like the people aren't worth it right
the good people like that's a dramatic
underell like one good
It's not worth seven figures.
The problem is that 90% of people just
suck. Like, right. And the best filter
is open source. The best filter is open
source. Like what? You're going to give
them a leak code? Like, okay, I I fail I
would fail. I would legitimately fail a
first year undergrad internship level
code screen, but I can build puffer lip.
So, what's that tell you? If your met if
your metric would literally hire, you
know, and I could have passed that same
interview when I was 18. So, if your
interview metric would hire 18-year-old
me, but wouldn't hire me building Puffer
Lib, what's that say about your So, like
it's really hard to interview people.
The only thing you can do is evaluate
open source. That's the only thing you
can do. And that's actually exactly what
Tiny does. If you like you look at them,
they have like bounties and stuff. Um,
and they like say like if you Only thing
that's a little scummy I think is just
like the amount of money that they're
paying for bounties is like probably a
tenth of what those features are worth
or less. So like that's the one thing
where it's like eh kind of enticing
people to do work that like with the
promise of payment without actually
really paying them anything close to
what the work is worth. Um yeah. Um, but
you know, I I get it because you know, I
get it because it's like tough because
it's like, you know, they accept a PR
and it's like I don't know if they end
up having to rewrite like a third of
them or they rewrite like half of them,
right? So, it's like it's kind of tough.
Um, yeah. Um, but yeah, definitely I
think having the um kind of talent
funnel be open source I think will be
the most effective way to hire people.
Yeah. And it's not all that like I also
grab people from my PhD contacts because
like they're people I've done research
with previously. Um
I will say that two I will say that two
of I mean I guess like two of the two of
three people at the moment are from open
source. So that's not bad.
Well, I I guess what I'm trying to say
is like having um like yeah, grabbing
people from like research and your
network is great. It just is like the
like for them to be able to be in your
network that, you know, they don't have
to go to like a university or whatever
kind of like same thing as you, same lab
or whatever. Um I know like able to hire
field. Yeah. Well, yeah. Uh, but I guess
what I'm saying is like being like
having that open source route allows
anybody like me who, you know, I'm I
can't really afford a mast's right now.
I'm able to contribute to puffer liib
and work on like master's I guess level
stuff and learn that kind of stuff.
Masters is a rough masters is always a
rough unless you do a master's as part
of a four-year. It's kind of just
[ __ ] The PhDs at least they pay
you. You don't pay. But yeah, that Yeah.
And well, I know there's some masters. I
think Princeton has a masters where you
teach, you're like a TA um and they give
you the masters for free with like food
and or um yeah. Um well, if well anyway,
back to kind of the entry points. If you
can do this kind of entry point that you
kind of have one which depends on Oh,
this is kind of cool. So you can make it
depend
on I can make it depend on extras. So I
can make it so that if you try to call
puffer without installing installing
modules that's but you can't it doesn't
look like you can pass args. Actually
you know what let's just all docs suck
these days. This is it's not even worth
writing docs because you just do this
anyways. It's like can you pass
arguments to uh
entrypt exposed by uh puffer? No advice
by
setups. I'm I'm I'm testing the chat GPT
search. We'll see which one gives us
better.
You cannot declare argument for an entry
point. Instead, you define a function
usually called. This takes args and
parks under console script. Uh, this
will grab grab sisv,
right? It would grab cisarch v uh arc
parse or cli library like click the
generate a wrapper script for. Yeah, you
can do it, but then you're just going to
end up you're literally going to just
end up calling arg parse on the results,
right? Yeah. Yeah. It's not It's going
to Hey, bet. Yeah. Which means you still
Hey. Hey, bet. Which means you still you
you won't be able to call it like via
import if that makes sense.
Ah well I guess you can say here I think
I found a way easier solution. Uh what
if you have like let's say like let's
say this is um
uh main entry here. He also I'm going to
cook something real quick. Let's add
like sweep entry and then
uh eval like this. Uh oh actually let's
remove that. Um and then we just say
sweep eval whatever. Um anyway, yeah,
something like this. You have this. But
then what you do is you then basically
all you do here is you do like um argu
like args equals parse args and then you
you do eval args.
Does that make sense? What that calls
args as if they're code,
but that doesn't No, no, no. I'm saying
pars args is like the oh oh wait remove
this. So you remember how you had the
um um like you had the the the train and
you basically have um you basically for
the fine train that you did basically
had it like this and then you had args
equals sparse args and then from here
you would have like the other stuff. So
you just you just want you want a
version of train that takes args instead
of taking having to parse the things.
Yeah. So basically you would have here
and then you have the args here and
that's kind of the thing you import. So
this is the stuff that you import.
These are the stuff like these are the
stuff that you import and these are the
entry points. Uh, and you can make it
funny. It's funny to me that it bothers
you yes less to have like these little
dangly entry functions versus having an
if statement.
But I guess you know what? Yeah. I mean,
it's cuz if statements um are in the
middle like it's cuz they're in the
middle of a bunch of crap, right? Yeah.
They're like in the middle of here. Like
I'm reading this. I'm reading I'm
reading and I'm seeing this. I'm like,
"Oh, where does where is this here?" And
then you know I'm reading I'm like okay
I'm like okay I guess this is where the
train is but train is called here well
train is checked for here I guess also
when this you know what I mean like I'm
like trying to think in my head okay
this hap train is called here but it's
also called here if load ID is not none
when is load ID not none and that kind
of stuff. a little tough. Now, I'm
looking at it and like, man, there's a
fair bit of stuff that you're going to
have to call at the start of each of
these damn things, right? Cuz like, so
we have you have to load in the
environment, the back end, right? You
have to load you have to make the policy
potentially wrap the policy, you have to
do distributed stuff, you have to
potentially load a checkpoint. Like
there's actually probably 10 lines of of
loading stuff if I do it at that level
of granularity like loading
here like loading stuff here like
loading all the crap because you don't
just call train of arts right call train
with like vemp policy
all the other things right
so and I'm guessing it requires for like
like each of these will have their own
loading stuff right it's probably going
to be very similar but yes
so I guess well yeah so it it's going to
be a little different just like similar
but what I guess I'm saying is like yeah
you'll have all that stuff and that
means here you'll have like a pure eval
loop or a pure uh eval kind of code here
you'll have the pure sweep code so it
doesn't have any of the loading stuff
it's just pure sweep um or pure eval and
you'll have the like the arguments here
for each of them that you just I don't
that's kind of
um interface or like the code structure
that makes sense for me is that you have
all this kind of fluff and then you have
the core functionality where you give it
you give it arguments here. It takes
arguments and it spits out and it it
basically just does its job kind of
as I don't know if stateless but as like
uh fluffiness fluffless as possible.
like it has none of the
um peculiarities of like oh I had to um
look for all these configs and then I
had to dynamically load them with the
given arguments and then I had to uh
make sure that this was right and this
was loaded correctly and this was like
that. So yeah, I'm just trying to think
how much stuff I'm going to be able to
get out of here when I because there is
still a lot there's like a lot of this
stuff that you still need to do
somewhere, right? You can't just not do
it. It's Yeah. So I have to figure that
out cuz like you know you need to
initialize logging somewhere. It's not
just like bring your own logger. At some
point the demo script has to like you
know decide all right it's going to be
Neptune and wi for the purpose of this
you know this file. Um,
yeah. So, like when you have like the
nap
tune like Yeah, you have this. Well, I
can take that out of there, but it's
still got like the experiment function
or whatever. Let's say that we still
have a function like experiment.
Experiment.
Like I can put it there. That's about as
right. That's about the best place I
could do. As far as you can pull it.
Yeah. Yeah. Um, and then like if you
just look at the file, right, there's a
whole bunch of stuff that's done here
like this local rank thing. I mean, that
has to be
that has to be set at least for both
train and for sweep. Um, right.
Um, let me think if there's any other
thing we can
do like and then if you scroll down
you'll see the model train like if you
scroll down you'll see the load code. So
you got make policy and then this load
ID is none. Look at that. That stuff
pulls down. So that actually lets you
load a policy from uh from Neptune or
Wani. So you can have a checkpoint
stored on there and it'll pull it down
and it'll load it for you. Ooh, okay.
Cool. I wonder what we're up to. We are
up to trying to figure out how to
improve user experience for uh the demo
and train files so that I can make those
changes, write the damn docs, and have
this release be done. Yeah. And it's
damn hard. It really is. I mean, I think
that you see it's like I think you see
that there's at least more perhaps than
you you might have initially considered
to do with this.
I like it's not like I don't give a [ __ ]
about this, right? Like this is the
primary thing that I care about and it's
like I spend a lot of time on this. It's
just like you see 900 lines of code, you
don't see like I like have you ever gone
and opened like the um the RL lib
source?
RL lib source. Yeah, go open their
source and try to figure out what the
hell's going on. Lib RL lib. Let's see.
RL this one, right? Uh, that's a fork of
it. Okay.
Yeah, that the Well, that's the RL lib
tutorial. This one. It should be any
scale RLIB.
Any scale. Okay. Well, let's I mean, the
fork should probably give us to the
right. I think this is different. I
think this is just like some other
random thing. I don't know. They have
tens They have like tens and tens of
thousands of lines of code and like you
would open up like po.py and po.py would
not contain the implementation of PO.
That's right.
No way. It would be like it would be
like distributed workflow of this and
that and like it like there would like
there wasn't a loss function for PO.
There wasn't like anything. Oh yeah,
this thing.
Ray is Ray is good, but they have RLI in
there. It's they're right there if you
scroll down. Oh no, no, it's in there.
No, it's in the It's in here. Oh, there
you go. There's our sub package. So
there are all their folders. It looks
like a file. C++. Okay, so you have the
core which is some Python has some RL
modules. Best find find the
implementation of PO. Go.
See, so RO module I guess should be
maybe pretty deep.
No more no more DS.
See
torch columns learner. Maybe
learner. Okay, maybe they do PO
different for each one of those now.
What's What's learner? What does learner
mean? Isn't that just
Look at the imports.
You can't hold typing against them.
Okay, I guess they're all Wait a second.
Oh, that's all imports. Jeez. Yeah,
that's all imports. Thought that was the
code. And then Torch Learner is uh Okay.
Oh, they have good good comments at
least.
Yeah. Uh let's see. So this is so this
thing and by the way like no sh like no
shade to these guys because they also
develop Ry and Ray is awesome and like
they like they got handed like what if
we apply fang engineering to RL and like
this is just like it's just not a
problem where you want to freaking do
that at all.
Look at all this two days ago.
Do they still I think Oh, I found it.
Yeah, they are. I don't I wouldn't be
too sure about that. Found the PO p.py.
Let's look at it. Oh no. Surely there's
something in there. Config. Is that just
a comment? That whole function is just a
comment.
Oh,
it's a class. No, this is a class. But
this is just a comment for this is the
init. This is the init. Okay. So, just a
bunch of config stuff, right? As
expected. Wait. Yeah, I have stuff here.
So, p config. Oh, wow. Look at this.
It just says class. Oh, here you go.
This is PO. No,
no. I guess kind
PO touching. Do you see? Uh,
yes. I mean, okay. You've got a P.
Keep going. Maybe you'll find some
object. Some real object too. Yeah.
Raining. I don't see PPO anywhere. Do
you?
Uh, no. API. I don't see PO in PO.Py.
Well, you got one of those. Oh. Oh, I
know where it is then. That's not going
to work. Oh, it's in the policy. Is it
in the policy? Maybe.
Policy class used with PO.
Oh, no. So this is what happens when you
try to apply fang style engineering to
RL right and object oriented is like
this. Have you seen Django? Have you
read the Django codebase? It's even
worse. This is like good dude. The
Django code. This is what I say. It's no
shade to them. Like this is like like
this is considered good engineering for
Fang, but it's like this is just not
what you want if like you're a
researcher trying to do anything. I kind
of take it back. This is how many
classes torch.
Okay. So, yeah, we're still we still
haven't found the code yet. Oh, we
haven't.
Policy V2. It might be in here. It might
be in here. It might be in here.
We still have not found any PO code.
Kind of nasty.
Fire torch.
P. This is what I had to This is like
And by the way, this was considered an
improvement for uh the first three years
of my PhD.
Oh my god. I've seen some demons. All
right. I've I've like I have bought
demons in this field. All right.
There is something that drove me to
spend the last couple of years of my 20s
fixing this field. See? Oh, sort of.
That's async PO, but I guess it's a
different N. That's a different
algorithm. This What about this one?
Nope. That's a different algorithm. Oh,
look. It takes Which is also a subass of
impala, which doesn't make any damn
sense. What is Godamn different
algorithm? Uh oh. Class class method
over
override. Oh, yep. Yep. Overriding some
stuff. Is this really? You can keep
clicking around here and we'll see if
you find any code. Look at this. Look at
this detailed documentation. Surely it's
And they're literally like, "Oh, yeah.
You want to see the implementation of
PO? Right here. Where is it?" Right
there. Where's the implementation?
Algorithm. So, you see, so how many
lines of code have you scrolled through?
I think you've already scrolled through
more lines of code than are in the
entirety of Puffer. There's the training
stuff right there.
Yeah. Oh yeah, let's see. Yeah, that
looks like training code, right?
Uh he's doing metrics and then he's
saying
uh so he's getting metrics and he's
saying steps. I saw that synchronous
sample function to see where what that
is.
To be fair, I guess I was the one who
asked them for that. So,
okay. Yeah, this is probably just, you
know, them uh I guess sampling the
environment something. I don't see any
learn I don't see any PO. Do you? Well,
you got to keep going. You got to look
at that synchronous parallel. I don't
know. I see learner group update.
Okay. Do you see the actual code like
where the loss gets calculated where uh
Oh, like where the update happened? We
don't see any of the actual PO code,
right?
I guess not. No, just just search for
KL. You could just back slash KL.
Surely KL
loss. Uh, no. K like loss like this or
KL divergence something. One of the loss
functions. One of the things that you
you should find very near loss. Find it.
Maybe loss. And we can search in this
repo. See what we find. There's a lot of
loss.
My guess is retrace easy.
Yeah. No way. Self-supervised loss
project API.
The the AI can do this. It should just
be looking. Yeah. Looking looking. Well,
this is I don't think this is co-pilot.
We can go to like say uh find me PP
uh
implementation. I'm going to do some
prompting. It's not going to be able to
do it. I'm sure. So, like you literally
now have resorted to AI to finding the
code. Well, I mean this is a job for an
AI searching through all this crap. So,
oh wait, look at this. It's saying
Well, yeah, you got to tell it. Yeah,
that's not actually it though. You got
find me the actual Oh my god. I can't
find it either. You got help me find the
actual code with the this particular
find the actual code
implementation. Uh your whole
your your
family lives you just get banned.
Depends on this. You're just going to
get banned from Gemini or Copa or
whatever this is. I don't know. Well,
listen. I am I am I am extracting
maximal val maximum accuracy. Okay. Oh
wait wait wait
wait. Is this it?
That's tensorflow policy loss. This
is policy loss comput 8 apo torch loss.
Oh maybe this is the closest thing we
can find.
Right. implements segregate value
function
apost functions. So I just there's
probably some code in here somewhere but
I don't think I've ever seen it. Um I I
so I think you get the point of this is
like I get the point. So our point was
not to try to do this because like they
have tens of thousands of lines of code
and like none of it makes any bloody
sense. like right so when I give you 800
lines of code or whatever and it's like
I don't even know how many times faster
than anything in that library and the
algorithm straight better and I don't
even think that they were shipping their
own CUDA kernels for like vrace and
stuff where we do like
I've already compressed the damn
complexity so much I get like I get it
and I still I think I can still make a
few changes and like get maybe the entry
points I'm going to see if I can do it
without branching I think yeah I think
the complexity like the issue is not the
complexity of the actual RL stuff for me
it's the the complexity of interface if
that makes sense like this is like like
how you have backend and front end code
this is like the backend code is fine
it's just the front end code has kind of
like a lot of complexity and it strips
away from the focus from the back end
which is tough because you need the
dynamic stuff for this thing to freaking
work. You do. Yeah. Um that's kind of
why I think stuff like this makes more
sense because yes, you're splitting it
up to functions, but you're splitting up
to functions that you don't have.
There's no like classes and mixins. You
can literally just GD and jump to the
function, you know?
All right. You can see the function.
Yeah. Anyway, yeah, that's kind of what
I'm thinking. We will attempt to do
these things maybe. Yeah. if if if you
think it's the correct way. Of course, I
think it's well, I think it's definitely
worth me trying for a bit to see more if
I can refactor things a little bit. Um,
if you can get it to something like
this, I think it'll be 10 times more
readable, at least like human readable.
Mhm.
Well, not 10 times, but like more
readable, you know? Yeah. It's just the
initial the initial barrier of like all
the dynamic crap we're doing cuz it's
tough cuz like the thing is that dynamic
crap used to be 300 lines, right? And
now it's like I've worked hard and I've
gotten it down to like 40 but it's still
annoying.
Yes. It's it's I'm not saying it's
unnecessary. I'm just saying if you're
able to just like sweep that under the
rag and like kind of basically put eyes
of the users focus on the train sweep
and eval like like on the actual meat
we love Coco standby what
check my
framework
okay yeah um I think I'm going to get
back to singing my env. Yeah, we get
some voids going, man. We want uh
Yeah, dude. I I have I'm having problems
right now where the um you know how you
have the binding. So, I read some of
that binding code here. Go to the init.
Uh I So, you're ideally not supposed to
have to deal with this because this is
PyTorch like Python C API annoying [ __ ]
Well, I do have to deal with it because
I noticed that um the way
my cursor sucks right now, but the way I
deal with the um try Neo Valley.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, way better. You're gonna say Here
you go. Now, now we now we got Neo. Now
you got a real editor. There you go.
Yeah. And it's riceed to completely
riceed. There you go.
Yeah, it is. It is rice to the maximum.
Uh I've got two plugins, my guy. That's
kind of a cool little like that's a kind
of a cool little browser though. Kind of
finding Yeah. Is that what the LSP?
What? This? Oh, you mean this telescope?
Telescope. Yeah. Okay. Does it actually
come with an LSP? I I don't have one of
those. No, no, no, no, no. This is me
adding LSP stuff. Um, I can
l disable lb. All right, there you go.
We're getting Yeah, now now we're
writing real code there. Yeah, we don't
need an LSP where we're going. Stop.
Stop. Here.
Remember that. Okay, here we go. All
right. It's still kind of rice, but
whatever. Yeah. Wait, did you have do
you have not do you have not equals like
like character replaced with equals with
a slash through it?
Well, it's it's like it's like a nerd
font thing. Yeah.
Let me just I'm gonna hide this because
I like having just this is this is now
fully rice. Now we're fully rice. We can
see the background. Is this Are you
running Hyperland as well or what is
this? No, no, I'm just running Gnome. Um
Okay. This is just Gnome. Okay. Yeah,
this is just Gnome. I can just um I have
it like rice. You see this? This is
actually custom made by me. I have this
thing where I can have bookmarks and it
shows me where like I I'm jumping to. So
like if I edit this now it's only these
two and I can kind of jump like
this. But yeah um another cool thing
about telescope is you can live grap it
and you can like see let's say I want to
see all the print stuff all the print
live grip. Yeah that's kind of nice.
It's really nice. That's you're
basically making an ID. So, well, if you
have all So, the question is if you have
all this stuff, why doesn't voids work
yet?
Boom.
Uh, well, that that's a good question.
Well, my problem with voids right now is
um if you take a look at the vect in it
and if you look at the there should be a
for loop somewhere here. this one um you
see how you increment um observations by
i here. So like um if I had an array
of like if I had an array like um this
yeah this is single agent right where I
have this like like well that's the
thing mine is not single agent yeah so
you didn't you didn't multiple examples
so open the snake open the snake one
open the snake file
I knew this was going to be your
question too oh my god I made you know I
made the same mistake all my
yeah that's Ellis here. Damn, you live
like this. No, I don't. I have a config
file that turns all these off. Like,
I don't know what you're linking me,
Ahmed. Um, how about
Hey, Weston. Hello.
Uh, yeah. Um, so that's the Syon. Go up.
Oh, you're saying this? Wait, what? Why
is the Syon? Go up to the top. Okay,
your fork is Yeah, it's cuz your your uh
your fork is super far behind. Um
Okay, here like open open uh open
browser.
Okay. All right. Go check go check that
file in in dev branch.
Okay. Yeah, let's go buffer lib.
Unless you're doing like daily work on
with puffer li, you're honestly going to
be pretty far behind. Your your progress
is hard to keep up with, Joseph. Dude,
I'm like working at half productivity at
maximum now because releases suck and I
never am productive around releases. No,
you're probably more productive than you
think. It's just the stuff you do is not
doesn't feel that productive. No, it's
like staring at monitor for a while and
then like I don't know, get bored, go
for go lift rocks.
This
you laugh. I have like four differently
sized rocks outside for lifting
purposes.
Okay. Right. This is kind of the Right.
This is the um you were talking about
where what if Wait, wasn't this merged?
I thought we had this merged.
God damn it. Oh, wait. What? What is he
on? Dev Branch. Yep.
And what's the I thought we had this
bloody thing merged already. Could be. I
mean, check it. It' be in the open PR as
if it wasn't. But did I not merge this
one? I'm pretty sure it got merged.
Um, what's the Oh. Oh, local snake
newbind PR.
Oh, is the PR still open? The PR is
still open. All right. Open neural MMO 3
then because it's there.
This snake's been waiting to to be
merged. Sorry, I've been I haven't been
around you about
I know you've been busy. I've been
trying to get place. I honestly haven't
even been busy. It's just that like
around releases it's just like my focus
and productivity
is which is why I try to get them done
quickly because otherwise it just drags.
The way I saw you do it actually um the
way I saw you do it on neural MMO is you
do a for loop and you vec you vecan it
and then you vectorize. I tried doing
that. It didn't work. Why doesn't it
work? Hello. Here, I'll show you. I have
it literally uh if I Oops. thing. What
did I just Let's fix your code. I want
to fix your code and then to go sleep.
That's a good idea. Yeah. Um so, if you
look at
voids.py, I have kind of two things. I
literally This is I took from your This
is I took from uh your thing. This I
took from neural MMO.
That look like the thing you were
talking about?
M times num voids.
Not quite. Did you pass the start of the
flat actions buffer,
dude? What?
Oh, no. Okay. Yeah, the actions actions
is an index there. Yes, actions is is
not the thing I was like trying to get
fixed. This is was the thing I was
trying to get fixed. This wasn't
working. I'm trying to fix them one by
one. This one wasn't working. Okay.
Observations. I would overwrite
observations. Like if I had observations
of like two kind of um two um like uh I
guess you can say
uh basically my observations for an
environment with uh two environments
with two puffers each will look like
this. And what would end up happening is
I would write first for in the first
environment I would write to these and
in the second I would write to these. So
the second would override this then
would write to this but it should be
here right should should like the
first have the indices wrong then.
Oh okay that was before. Wait you have
one you have one hardcoded right there.
Hang on. What's that one? Okay, one is
the uh num
um number of events cuz with this is for
a single environment, right? Hang on.
Well, you have it as like you don't even
have this. You just have seed or
something. You want to Yeah. Yeah. I So
that's why I'm confused. Hang on.
You're also missing the latest. We
actually have sanity checks now on the
latest one. So it'll like give you real
error messages if you screw stuff up. Uh
for me, what screwed for me here was
like a pipe error. When I when I used
this code, it was a pipe error. Well,
yeah, you have two arguments there.
That's not that's not the like that's
not it doesn't take two that doesn't
take both of those. It only takes one of
those. Yeah.
And then the version that you're on
doesn't have the latest version of our
code has an error message. If you do
that, it'll error on you.
H this one. So let me just Oops. Yeah.
Add that. Okay. So this one if I look at
um you see how really it does not uh cuz
if I look here you see how it's like
tupil size argument uh okay so here you
go yeah so
uh this is ve and if we look at numves
right this is uh this num
n where's num there's seed yeah this is
the C it's argument six and then like
argument five is numbum and is this one
right so I was like argument
that's in veinet that's not in a net go
back
back to my to the p here all right so
it's not ve what the [ __ ] that's not
binding veinet oh neural mmo is yeah you
copied the code wrong that's not what's
in neural mmo it's envet oh it's not
envet oh it's it's from my binding
C
file. Is it from this file?
That's fine. No, it's
I'm saying like go back. You're calling
the wrong function. You're calling you
are calling uh veckonet when you're like
you're calling vein in the loop. It
should be calling envit. Beckinit is the
vectorzed version of that function. Um
you're trying to vectorize something
that's already vectorzed.
Okay, that's API wrong.
Yes.
So, what you're saying is this this
should not be vein in it. This should be
enet. Yeah. And then you can delete the
one parameter,
right? You can index your flat actions
as well.
Yeah. This um you have to index. Yeah, I
would have to index it to like it just
needs to be continuous memory, you know.
You just it's getting a pointer as all.
Yeah, but it would be like you don't
have to flatten it is what I'm saying.
Like it can get right. It doesn't have
to be flattened. It was just flattened
in the Syon thing and I kind of ported
it. Yeah, it was messy. It
is the way that like this is the way
that you would want to do it. Now,
another issue. This is kind of the issue
that was I guess this issue I was
literally solving like before I spoke to
you about the API docs or like the
document like documentation. Well, this
isn't documented yet because it's new.
Yeah, I Yeah, I'm not talking about
that. I'm talking about the
documentation of the puffer RL. Um, what
I was what I was having issues with is I
pass like this report interval. This is
just right now a ve in it that
is very accurate. We don't usually pass
report interval to the C. Um really
because the report interval in Python is
different from the C one. Well, we don't
usually have one in C.
Uh where did you see a report interval
in C?
Well, it's not H. Well, I have um uh
somebody's linking me.
What's this? Who's linking me? Why Why
can't this copy?
I don't know why this link doesn't copy
either.
I had like log um let me see if it's in
snake
maybe. H um log. Yeah. Uh, not log
buffer size. But you had like
[Music]
um add
log and log if done.
Oh, I see. Okay.
[Music]
So, I was
it. H. Yeah. Okay. And if I go
to So, right
now, you're saying I don't need this
port
interval. Um, oh, also my logging wasn't
working. That was another issue.
So interval. Yeah. Yeah. This is um this
is very this is like very similar to
like the type of thing that you would
see in um like a 231N assignment because
when you said that this was like a
framework, right? This is this is a
framework that's relying on numpy for
all of the actual array ops. um you know
like the tiny tiny NN frameworks that
are like actually reasonably paced or
GPU accelerated in uh in CUDA for the
most part.
Um but yeah, this is more like
uh like
exercise like level stuff. Does this run
with GPU? No, this is this is
essentially this is this is a numpy
wrapper that is like this is a numpy
wrapper autograd essentially. Um this is
like to be fair there's a there a bunch
of operations in here but this is like
the type of thing that you implement for
like 231n as a learning exercise that is
a classic self backward. No literally a
numpy rapper if you're if you're just
learn that is that's literally the way
that you learn. That is the best way to
learn. I forget because yeah I uh yeah
okay that's if that's what you're doing
that's like that's totally that's like
that is the best way to learn this
stuff. So recognize it from from the
intro to whatever uh video uh we have
this I was I was watching so
so I guess I should lock it log it at
every tick or every end tick every Wait,
let me take what's your what's your what
are you doing? M tick. So no no no you
don't do this every tick. You log, you
update. So the way that you do it with
the new system is you increment the log.
You increment, there's one log, you
increment it every time a boy dies or
every like fixed I guess there's no
death. So you just do it like a fixed
number of intervals, I guess. So that's
why you have an empty. Okay, I see why
you have two report intervals. That's
fine.
So what should I do there? Should I just
have two report intervals?
They can be the same interval, but like
Yeah, there's no reason for them to be
different. Yeah. So, what I'm saying is
pass to the C. I want to pass it to C so
that they're same, you know. Yes. No,
that's fine. You can pass it to the C.
It's most don't need that. So, that's
fine. Let me see where the this guy's
code just went. Yeah.
flatten problem is maybe bet can give me
input on this is
that doesn't show up like it's
um I have this something cool it
probably doesn't show up because you
weren't indexing the actions right
you've implemented a lot of nuts and
bolts here
what I'm talking about is like the
report interval doesn't show up like
it's zero when and I pass it one and
like no I just I'm literally yes the
these are incorrect but this works this
doesn't which doesn't make sense like
I'm passing it at least one here you're
passing what this one I see zero so this
report interval like if I print report
interval here print uh report interval
Um let's say so report interval like
this interval right well yeah
self.report report interval. If I print
this, this will be one while the one and
C will be zero. Open your binding.
That's kind of my issues. My binding.
Oh, right. Oh my god. You're Yes, I know
what my problem is. Damn it.
I love telepathically guessing people's
errors. Hey, what was my boards? Oh, you
didn't you didn't put it in binding.
Where's Yeah, I I didn't set it like
this. I didn't set it like this.
Uh what was it? Um uh did I actually
med?
So this one is not fun. Com is not fun
to do. I will give you that. Con forward
and backward is a total pain.
What's back and forth? Con uh
convolution forward and backward is Oh
con 2D.
Massive massive pain. But you just have
it as well.
It is like it's all sort of it's all
sort of a pain. Turns out turns out it's
like pretty pretty handy to use. I've
done it this way before as well. Yeah.
This is how you understand what what's
actually happening, right? This is not
the way it's actually usually
implemented to be fair, but it's like
it's a reasonable thing to do. I
transform it's raw.
I I'm ashamed I haven't implemented uh
con from scratch. I only implemented
like MLP stuff. It's a pain. Not with
numpy with like Just plain Python like
no numpy ready
buffer lib and that's you know to me
puffernet.h isn't real puffer puffernet
puffernet.h isn't real puffernet.h can't
hurt you puffernet.h H
you haved in there. This comd
in the background. This is the number of
four loops. Say uh this is the number of
four loops a comp. Oh my god. If you
think that if you think that this is
torney for loops, you simply just don't
know what a com is. Oh yeah, that's this
is the correct Yeah, you will you'll
have at least three nested because of
the um
yeah but like but don't you just have a
square you iterate over you basically
iterate the square throughout the batch
image batch size out
channel out channel so every out channel
height and width and then you have to go
over the input dimension input kernel
height kernel width every output
dimension. It depends on every input
dimension. Wait. Yeah. So, batch size.
Yes. That Okay. Six without batch.
Yeah. Okay. Not three. Um. Wow. Really?
Okay. Interesting.
From what I understood, conv is
literally just a square. Also sucks to
do. So, this is this right here is uh is
one of the more annoying CS231N
uh exercises. So if you're doing this to
learn this is good. I am to call will
not make it faster even in popular
because you are material you are
material
materializing the intermediate values.
The correct implementation of com I was
just talking with a fantastic CUDA dev
about this today. The correct
implementation of com is really
obnoxious because you don't actually
materialize the IM to
call. Yeah, the math is not
fun. You're on the right track though.
If you're actually like committing to
doing the work to doing all this stuff,
you are on a very good track for like
learning productive deep learning stuff.
Like this like learning the low level of
this will teach you a lot more than uh
yeah, most folks know.
Uh okay. So now that I have the report
interval, it should work.
I know if I
do build you did self attention as well.
Nice. Yeah. I mean this is this is an
autograd. This is how all these things
work. No, it is in the
paper, but I checked it by hand. It's
not that bad. Well, some of it's
annoying.
What's this? Loading in like existing
weights for inference or are you
training? Yeah, you're loading pre-train
and doing inference. Yeah, cuz your
thing is going to be way too slow to
actually train like a sizable network.
You could fine-tune it,
but be slow. Nice. I I need this. I
think you'll like this. This is this
this file here is inference only, but uh
we use this this is actually used in our
demo file. Like we use this on
puffer.ai. So like this these uh this
network that is playing this game and
like all of these games are running that
code live in your
browser, which is kind of cool.
Here we go. Yep. Yep. Report interval is
working. Nice. Nice.
Uh now that I have that working, now I
need to make you can see it's not any
harder in C. Right. Actually, the Yeah,
it wasn't the the my com is literally as
short as your IM2 call in. Of course,
it's a pain. It would be a pain to do
the backwards with this, but like it's
not so bad. And then you can actually do
fun things with it.
I think Spencer added com 3D which is uh
a lot of four loops. This is nine four
loops.
Thanks Spencer.
And I'm guessing LSTM as well when it
runs when you put it through CUDA it
does a lot of uh like vectorizing. This
is just a Yeah, I know.
Yeah, but I mean you could run it on
CUDA. It wouldn't be that. Isn't there a
way to make it to make it vectorized?
Well, I could just write CUDA. CUDA is
not that different from this code. But
the thing is that these these neural
nets are like 100 most of these are like
100k params. Some of them are like a few
hundredk params. And like the thing is C
is really fast and Python is really
slow. So like you can actually run small
neural nets in just naive C even though
you can't do it in naive Python.
Okay.
And then you can do stuff like this,
which is cool. I don't know. Like
lowlevel dev was such a big unlock for
me. Like it's it's just awesome. And
like the thing is I'm It's so mad that
it took me so many years to found to
like discover that I love this stuff.
But like my systems professor just
sucked. like uh he was like a smart guy
who is just terrible at explaining
literally
anything. So it's like okay well I guess
he is just super complicated then. Nope.
Okay. Now my problem is no
logging. I get no user logs. Am I
getting steps? I'm getting CPUs going
through.
Am I not? Yeah, I'm not stepping. Why am
I not
stepping?
Okay. Someone like you can see this is
easy
knowledge. No, I know this is hard,
dude. I spent like literal thousands of
hours from age 16 to
age no age like probably 15 to 17 or 18
like just grinding out trying to figure
out the basics when there were way fewer
resources. It's not fun. It took me
forever. All right. Like I know this
stuff is hard.
It I it took me two weeks to understand
and implement um uh like the back like
um gradient descent. So, oh, I spent
longer than that. I spent way longer
than that because like I was like I was
a sophomore in high school trying to do
that stuff in like the worst goddamn m I
was implementing it first I tried to
implement a neural net in Java which was
obscene and then I tried to do it in mat
lab. All right. And then I tried to do
it in mat lab and then finally I did it
in python with numpy and I still got
that wrong and I could only get like 82%
on mnest. All right. And then eventually
I finally kind of figured it out. All
right. Uh Joseph, uh if you direct your
attention to my screen, you'll see
something uh that might trigger you.
Oh gosh. That when you can see this was
me in like No, this was like 11th grade
uh implementing 100% Java. 100% Java.
Oh, you're a relatively new grad then,
huh?
Oh man, I've literally done that by
then. I've literally done that, man. I
did that exact same thing. I had every
freaking I think I Mine was even worse.
At least you have input layer Java. All
right. Mine was I tried to do each
neuron was a class. Okay. Oh, no. Here.
This is my This is my um This is my uh
gradient descent. That's better than
mine was. All right. All of this more
here. Yeah. the it's all of this
basically. Yeah, this is my gradient
descend. I'm calculating. Actually, I'm
sure I have some of my freaking partials
and then I'm updating the layers and
these are all just for loops cuz I did
not know what matrix like that matrix
multiplication can do this easier. I was
just like, oh, I'm just going to for
loop
this and it works. It just
I have here these are code
Well, I can tell you that good math has
a lot of symbols. This was my like
neural net. This was me trying to figure
out neural net math.
Oh, the way I figured it out is I
like sketched it with arrows. That would
be like derivative here, then I arrow it
with No, that math is definitely
something that's important to
understand. This was like, and the thing
is, I was so proud of this. Like, at
some point, I think I like wrote these
equations on like like on like a small
like blackboard thing and then like hung
it up somewhere.
I was like so proud to have like come up
with this dumb [ __ ] and it was like,
h man,
I feel that. But my environment right
now doesn't do steps. What could be the
reason?
Are are you you want to know the cool
thing?
Uhhuh.
You can actually just run GDB on it.
Yes. You don't have multiprocess.
That's kind of what I was. You can run
GDB through Python. I have Watch this. I
have this actually. This is actually
really cool. Um it's a GDB front
end. Uh let me see if I can Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Here we go. Here you go. Watch
this. So, I'm just gonna I'm going to
blow your mind.
This a GDB right here. You have like
This is your, you know, your GDB
console. What's all this? What's all
this extra like gross stuff around the
terminal?
This is He's made an ID debugger for
Middle East don't understand the map.
They just know hugging face trainer
trick. Yeah, that's that's kind of what
happens. Like
you can't really do anything when that's
all like you don't really get anything
done. I have this when that's all you
know though using Python debugger
recently. Uh yeah.
So what are we looking for?
What are we looking for? Uh this is this
is the problem. Like I can't you can't
control F stuff like like it doesn't let
you in VS buffer you control F stuff
like I need to control I don't know what
you're doing
I'm I'm going to the library you see me
here in the bottom I'm okay where should
I set the like yeah but I got a terminal
man and I'd be done by now
where I'm I'm trying to figure out where
to send it where to uh whoever you want
like you got to get something to start
put it in step
in step where step.
There's your file. Literally, it's like
you just break on the file, colon the
function name. Wait, did you call it
Cstep? Yeah. Uh I I it's probably in the
demo, right? So, it's like B and then
Man, I don't even know like this like
all this like CLI rising and then all
this like and then like gooey tools and
those two don't go together. You know
what? Here, GDB. Okay, you're good.
Yeah, there you go. That's way better.
Now you just get the function name and
you just break there. Step.
Uh, what do you mean get the Well, I
need to find You can break like puffer
lib. Oh [ __ ] Like you can just type the
Find the file. Just type step. It'll
break on every step. Well, I don't know
there. No, you break on step. I It might
not. You might need the path like this.
Yeah, try that. Yes. Hit Y. Okay, let's
see if that does anything. I actually
don't know if that works. that
it it it should it should trigger every
single step. Use these file. You didn't
run it as a You didn't run Python.
Wait, did you? Well, he's got No, he
did.
Python demo. What did he miss in the
command? Uh, it might be that you have
to reference your specific Python uh
path. No, should Oh, you know what it
is?
Okay. Yeah. See? Yep. So now I need to
the right path. Um I do break step,
right? There you go. That looks better.
End user test.
Uh what do you mean? It's Docker. You
have not embraced the Docker yet. I have
not. Whale superiority. I am I am in
Docker container. Um we
can
I
guess. Okay.
So, okay. Well, you know, there's no
steps. So, I guess we can pause it. Is
there a way to pause? So, it didn't
break yet.
I guess either that or it doesn't know
the the full path to the step function.
Um, I think it I think it hasn't gotten
there. So, it's not getting not getting
to your step. Well, I mean, you can just
put you can just put a break. You can
python break point. Oh, you know you
know what it's stuck on. I 100% bet you
um if I do breakpoint. Um I'm still
using the
demo.py. Is it you get autocomplete here
or you just
uh demo.py slash Well, now I need to do
what line? Let's see.
Demo.py. Um, let's It's probably
something here. So, yeah. Line
11. Yes. Uh, then run. Are these West
Coast people or these just people up
like watching me at 10 20 watching debug
stuff at 10:20.
Looking the uh Welcome Twitch and
YouTube folks. This is RL contri
contributor debugging RL things. Um,
here. All right. You too can write cool
reinforcement learning environments and
get them working in Puffer Lab and get
code reviewed live. Yes. And contribute
to science.
Yes. Okay. Easier than you think. So,
what I'm going to do is I'm going to I
think I know. Yeah. Yeah. I know the
issue. It's my computer. My GPU drivers
are just bad and they don't run. So,
it's sometimes they just can't run
stuff. Uh, literally. train.device CPU.
Yeah, good point. Um, AMD card.
I know. I have um I have a 1080. Oh
jeez, dude. That's literally older than
my paper weight.
Watch.
1080 is like it actually slows down
trading.
Oh, here we go. No. Yeah. No. No. All
right. He's gonna go get this is this is
my paper weight here. Okay. You see
this? Yeah. It's it's it's better than
my my GPU currently. My actual paper
weight is better than your GPU.
Listen, don't make fun of my of my my
broke my broke. That is that is better
than the GPU that I'm looking at
getting.
I heard you GPU are you looking to get?
I heard you.
All right. Hey, no. No, it's not. Oh,
wait. Wait. It's loading. It's It's
loading. Let Let
it. Okay. See.
And remember, I have a 3600X, so not the
best CPU here. Well, also you can just
run Breakout to see if it works.
Like crazy. Do you want me to run it
through GDB? No, I just want you to run
Breakout.
See if it works. Oh, right. Uh, we can
do that. the hyperparameters like batch
size and MIDI batch size
uh if your hardware right I still have
to adjust that right um breakout mine
can barely handle it what breakout no
just the big the big batches well we're
getting new hardware soon so there will
be more hardware around
let's see
we're getting two tiny boxes so that's
plus 12 GPUs for puffer
and I actually had an idea for the tiny
boxes. Well, like if we want to have
multiple people working on them at once,
why not just have like Docker container
per GPU and people SSH to the Docker
container? Well, we would give you
Docker container per GPU. I guess we
could expose the Docker containers
themselves to No, they won't. Instead of
SSH directly to the machine, SSH to the
Docker container. Yeah, you can do that.
Or you can run one command once you're
in it. Either way, sure.
Um, yeah, it's not running. Um, um, my
breakout is not running. There could be
any number of reasons why it's not
running. Yeah. Well, so that's not If
Breakout isn't running, then that's not
it's my PC. Yeah, it's my PC. Or you're
on a junk code version or any number of
things, right? Um, I mean, I
can I rebase to the new one and my voids
will still work. Did anything change?
Yeah, I mean, save your code, but yeah,
that's what you should do.
almost certainly going to break. But I
mean, I don't break that much stuff. No,
no, not because of stuff moves, but
Oh crap.
Wait, it moves a lot. What did I change?
Oh, this is also really cool. No, no,
not it's not like the old days, Joseph.
The terrifying refactor when when uh
when
Vector, you're watching rice right now.
Th this is like ultimate rice here
having undo
tree. You have all these tools, but
voids doesn't work. Yeah, Boyd doesn't
work. Doesn't work. What my guy, you
know, you know what your competition is
here? It's like I got uh I got myself
Neoim. I got two plugins. I got I got
like a little bit of syntax highlight
for Python maybe that does like I don't
know, it makes my code harder to read.
And then I got uh I got Super Maven for
like the typing buff. And that that's
what I got. I got that. I got I got LS.
That's what that's a good one. I got
like sometimes if I'm feeling really
fancy I maybe I have a GP and then I
have like I don't know maybe the 10
actual BIM like shortcuts that I
actually use. That's it.
Yep. That's all I got.
Good reading config
args. Wait, actually do are these your
are these prints in demo? I don't think
I'm just going to Yeah, I'm just going
to do this gate reset. Uh, you should
you should just you should make sure
that you keep your code somewhere.
Well, I'm I'm just going to get reset
the files that I know that are not kind
of my code like art pole like that. You
know what I mean? Rebase.
Just don't screw it up. Well, well,
first let me I'm just going to commit my
files. So, it'll be puffer lib uh
voids. H or just do that. Yeah, be smart
to even push, you know.
Let's see. Yeah, I will push uh well
um add amented
multi- agent um
uh in
its
uh make log slashreport interval
configurable commit message. I mean you
I like having good commit Well, at best
I can commit messages. I write try to
write nice commit messages.
Uh binding C. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um
to add that Oh, yeah. I'm going in a
couple minutes cuz I got to sleep. Yeah.
Yeah. Set report. I've That's actually
I've not gotten good sleep the last
couple of days, which is one of the main
reasons I've been dopey today. Yeah.
It's the release.
Yeah. Yeah.
Voids. What did I change here? Get up
and get some good exercise in the
morning. Make use of all these fun
things, which actually you can see them
now in the evening. Like you can't see
any of the stuff in the background in
the morning because of the lighting.
It's pretty cool though.
Good.
Oh, so what I'm going to do now since
that is all of these I can just reset
because that's not stuff I want changed.
Now I just got to figure out the
command. What was it? Um it command to
reset local changes to remote.
Joseph, do you have like the recommended
like alpha range for me? Holy hell.
You're getting miked way the hell down,
my friend. Yeah, you're right now. Uh,
all right. Alpha range. Like what alpha?
What parameter? The hyparameter for
entropy.
That's not like temperature. Oh, is it
alpha? I kind of forgot. Do they know
temperature and alpha is technically the
same thing. They use alpha. I forget
what symbol they even use for entropy.
Um, yeah. Uh, so it's really
envend. Um, some M's like a little bit
of entropy, like up to 0.05 on the high
end, and some of them like literally any
entropy screws them up. So, you kind of
want to log sweep that thing between
like 01 and like 05.
Then log space. I would sweep it.
And that's
that's what's being That's the That's
the divisor for the softmax function,
right? I'm not crazy. No, it's not the
It's a separate loss entropy is a
separate loss
term. Entropy is a separate loss term
that's that measures how spread out your
uh your logits are.
Okay. Um here, let me find it for you.
Push. Okay. get.
So if we look even at old clean puff
because it's going to be the same
entropy. If I go to my
thing already up to date, but I got to
sync the fork
update
branch.
Um well uh Joseph, what should I do if
um like I'm updating the fork and it's
still like I can't run the um breakout
for example on my PC.
What should I do? Well, you should
figure out what the heck is wrong with
your setup.
You know, do a clean install. Like if
you have some disk space, you should
probably just like Well, I guess you
can't install our I guess it depends
what if your GPU supports the CUDA
version on our Docker. You could just
install that on branch.
What? Yeah, because it's not there.
Because it's not there. It's it's it's
migrated
to void. So this is our entropy, dude.
This is You see it's literally logit
times probs negative that some
It's normalized logits. It's like this
thing just measures how spread out your
logits are is all it is.
There's not even uh I mean I guess
technically the prob calculation has a
soft max in it but that's it. Yeah,
that's that's that's the that's the one
I'm talking about. That's where alpha is
the
hyperparameter. I sent I sent the line
of code. Uh
um
I don't think that's
that's not I don't think that's how
I don't think that's how entropy works.
I could be really dumb because I keep
switching between DQN and PO. So that is
that's temperature. That isn't
Is that [ __ ] the same as I don't
think it is.
environmental. Dude, I haven't looked at
I haven't seen something like that in so
long because it's just not used in RL. I
don't know if there's some equivalence.
Um, let me think.
So, like I should just like remove the
divisor.
Well, what we do is what we normally do
is we normalize logit so that we don't
pass garbage to softmax. So, we like
subtract the min and then we compute
entropy as a separate term. We use that
probability and then we multiply by like
norm logits or whatever implementations
in this pietorch file.
Um
yeah, but like what are you what are you
doing with this? Is this like your DQN
implementation or No, I've switched to
PO. This is PO. But I I'm probably going
to get a little bit confused here which
is why I'm making sure that I'm getting
this right. Like if you have a correct
very different if you have a correct
Sudokco implementation with relatively
easy levels and like a correct action
space it's very likely that Puffer will
just solve it out of the box for you.
Okay. So where where would I look that
up? Like what uh what exact file am I
looking? So you just look at any of our
existing M's, right? So like we've got
Puffer Lib, we've got our Ocean M. And
if you just pick like I don't know pick
a simple one pick like cartpole or
squared like here we have
api you can have it in C or you cannot
have it in C right you could imagine
like you either just do it in C or you
write the for loops okay you have this
little tiny end binding and then here is
the C codeh file this
cartpole we have like a couple required
things like you have to have a log that
has some stuff in
And then other than that, the only thing
you write is this very short binding
file that just tells you what to log and
if you need any
variables and then that's it. You just
run your train and you can run your
train and you can import it like you
just you add your config file puffer lip
config like you know they they all have
a config file
and you can just you can add anything
you want in here to sweeps and add other
hyperparams but if you don't even put
anything here it'll still like just load
the defaults for
you and like it's pretty it's pretty
darn to get stuff when you have this.
Then I should be able to have something
that can like work. It might not be
optimal, but it'll work. Yeah, you
should you should really have something
that works. And then like what happens
is in 90% of the cases, people have made
at least one, usually several errors
with the data in their environment,
either data or reward or action space
formulation or something like that. And
then you spend time figuring out what's
wrong with that.
Yeah. Because like right now I have a PO
that is performing as well as just a
random number generator.
Yeah. Which means it's not learning
anything,
right? It's like really it's really easy
to
um it's like an entirely different field
when you're just like rolling your own
stuff versus you're using like our
actually good
implementations because I mean this is
literally what I've been doing like for
the past full year, right? And like
something like
Sudoku, you could train that thing at 3
million steps a
second. So
like it's kind of hard to not just solve
everything when you have a pretty decent
algorithm that's just running that fast
and then you have like sane defaults
that have come from me running several
thousand experiments on all of the M's
in Puffer.
What I would do is I'm not suggesting
that you don't implement your own
algorithms. Like you should implement
your own algorithms to learn, but what
you should do is you shouldn't do your
own environment and your own algorithm
at the same time because like you're
going to get confused to where the bugs
are, right? So if you want to learn
algorithms, then use a known good
environment or it's not any okay.
Uh what would you recommend for a known
good environment? Just like use our
breakout implementation for instance.
That's
easy, right?
Thanks. If you want to play with like if
you know if you want to play with like
with algorithms, you can do that for
sure.
If you want to follow along, by the way,
like after I finish this released,
literally the next thing on my docket is
um hardcore algorithm devon, which I'm
going to be just going through tons of
deep mind papers trying to figure out
all the new stuff that Deep Mind has
done and like what things would actually
be generally useful versus which are
kind of like academic fluff. Um there a
whole bunch of unsolved things and like
open questions in RL I'm going to be
looking at be a ton of time for
algorithms but you definitely want to
have like an end to end working in RL
like you should get something working
first just so that you have the
experience
[Music]
commit
um config slash
Okay. Hey. Um based
uh create
um branch.
[Music]
config.
Okay. Cannot
this is I'm just doing some merch
FP16. So, this is why our uh AM is not
working because it's nerfed on Nvidia
chip. AMD hardware could be an out for
us to be fair. I don't know if we want
to go down that or
not. Would be cool.
[Music]
Oh, there's still sucks though, right?
Where are the C
extensions? C extension names. Right.
Name it
Okay.
Um and set off
[Music]
p get
Hey, successfully
rebased. Now,
let's look. Wow, I just realized VS Code
doesn't have an extension for Syon.
Oh, it does.
Not an official one. Not official, but
you can. It's not official. Why are you
doing? Well, you can do Syon if you
want. Our new stuff is not
Syon. It doesn't have an official Syon
one, which I think is fun. I mean, I
wrote my own syntax highlighting for
micro for
Syon. Okay, good. Now that I have that,
okay,
I update it to the latest branch.
Hilarious. Oh, I've been talking to
myself.
Like I was
muted. I
see. We don't have demo.py anymore,
right? It's
um sorry.
name. Is it uh is it inside puffer
lib? Same same. It is. Your run command
is python.
Python_luff.
Clean. I should probably not just have
everything be named some variation of
What is it? Is that just syntax
highlighting or what? Like
that's quite literally just syntax
highlighting. Just just you got to you
got to you just got to rip that band-aid
right off, you know. Just got to rip
that band-aid right off.
Did you make this UI bet for Grock?
Yeah. What is uh what did you make the
UI with? Is this Ray Lib or what is it?
I I've made it with a it's it's all one
file index.html. It's all in one file.
Oh, it's it's just h Okay. It's full. I
hit it raw.
Yeah. Oh, I guess yeah, it's a web page,
so duh. Yeah. Well, not not Well, there
are various ways to do it like that
involve lots of JavaScript files and
other messes like CSS files and like I
don't want to get into all that.
No. Oh,
I don't like front end.
Uh By the way, got stuck on uh
Jigglypuff disabled its ember and it
didn't know how to just press up or down
to pick a different move. No module
named Syon. That's kind of pathetic. I
literally had to just
add in the in the battle prompt now.
It'll work
on. Okay, I see. Say, uh I need to do
Python setup or these are not real
stats.
That was the not real stat. You have
69420 viewers with 1,000% win rate and
420 420 steps taken. I mean that
was undo it. You those are the numbers
that came out. Definitely didn't
personally program those numbers.
I got to sleep guys. Can you hopefully
you helping get this thing work? If not,
I do tomorrow. I got to sleep. Tomorrow
I'm going to try to do that refactor.
I'm going to try to do docs. I'm just
going to try to like actually get as
much damn stuff as I can done because
this this release needs to be done. Like
I'm sick of it. Like we have all the
results. The experiments are coming in.
Actually, why don't you know the last
thing we'll do is let's just take a look
and see if we have any any results in
and I will not bother you and I'll
finish this damn end. Finish ends is a
good idea.
Yeah. So, are we gonna are we gonna do
continuous? I I haven't I haven't tried
to to troubleshoot continuous. I hate
you. Pie torch. It better work.
Okay, dude. I hate my GPU
install torch.
Wait, wait. How much VM does it take?
Yeah, you you've still you've still got
a better GPU than me in literally every
way. Oh, there we go. Well, the problem
is is that look at this. I'm getting
runtime errors because PyTorch 12.6 is
not good with CUDA this. So, I'm going
to have to do passage right of passage.
Have to do um PyTorch and they have a
way to install
CUDA was completely broken on Windows.
literally just didn't work because I had
to install like 12 different versions of
it and even then it was broken. Are you
running on? Where was the doc? No, I
switched to now. Yeah,
like just you can just
install on Windows. No, they they were
pre-installed pre-installed. Yeah,
sometimes you have to manually get the
right things.
If you want my opinion, if you have a
Windows machine with an Nvidia GPU, do
not use their GPU installer. Manually
install it. Oh, yeah. 100%.
Um I was um they released that when they
changed the um the control panel, they
broke all the drivers and it was
supposed to be a that um apparently only
broke the 40 series, but for some reason
it also broke mine. And I had to
manually find it and uninstall it. And
because I had prom controls on the
machine, it was absolutely hell because
I had to enter the code like 10 times.
So I'm constantly calling my dad over
like, "Dad, you got to type in the code.
Dad, come back. You got to type in the
code."
This is why I should be able to use my
own PC like a real boy.
That's That's freaking rough.
Mhm. I remember having, you know, I had
parental controls and back then you can
um you could have exploited them by cuz
they would pop in a delay of like half a
second and if you click a specific I
found if you click a specific thing, it
would not pop at all. So I would just
have unlimited time on my PC. Well, it
wasn't just controls. was also that
because of the prom controls, I didn't
have admin, right? Yeah, that that that
was your issue. Well, my issue was not
playing not being able to play Counter
Strike,
man. I remember when Counterstrike 1.6
came out, that was good stuff. You want
to play Counter Strike? I want to use my
GPU. We are not the same. Yeah, y'all
are weak. When my parents took away my
computer, and granted this is years ago,
I literally cut the internet. Like cut
the Ethernet cords. Why? Why Ethernet?
What? Okay, first off, it was dialogue.
I had 288 in in those days. And the
parental controls were they took the
keyboard. They take the keyboard and
mouse. They literally item. I went to
Walmart and got got a new keyboard which
I kept and and brought with me so I
could use the computer. It was one My
parents took my things. I went in their
room and took their things. All right.
Well, I wasn't I wasn't petulant like
that. Although I've been called abrasive
recently by my parents, who are great
people, by the way.
Mhm. Yeah. Funny. All right. Um, yeah.
See you. I'll see you guys. I'm I'm I'm
launching a couple last What? All I'm
doing is I'm just I'm ablading real
quick like some sweeps just like a
couple small things.
[ __ ] like just so I have something
going overnight so I just get some more
data. Um,
I'm gonna have this freaking end of
working. Yeah, it's just they're like
all these little tiny
obnoxious obnoxious. No, just it just
overlooks by me, you know,
just very like like not adding that in
the bindings.py file and stuff like
that, you
know, adding the um lots of little, you
know, details. Yeah.
Am I on puffer box five? Oh yeah, I
shouldn't be touching this. What am I
doing? That's the wrong box.
That's Aaron stuff. Yeah,
uh let's just make new.
Okay. Python
[Music]
download. Oh, right. There's no demo.pay
it.
So, so let's see if I can figure figure
out how to get around this disabled
move. Cursor is on which appears to be
strong available move. So, I'll press A
to select and use it.
No module here. I see that the member is
disabled. You should probably add psutil
to
[Music]
um another damaging scratch. It's in
clean right now. I have to move it
around. It worked. No module named
gymnasium. Pip install puffer lib of
clean
RL bracket clean. Oh, so UV. Yeah. Yeah.
UV pip install dash Pick a scratch.
Migly puff is dead.
Lean. Oh no.
Is actually
nice. Like it's fast. It like doesn't
Yeah, but you know it's written in Rust.
So like Yeah, rust rust people are kind
of weird, you know.
Come on.
I don't I don't want PyTorch 12.6. I
want I want the PyTorch I but more like
Jiggly poof go in the flash.
You go UV pip
is. Where's Okay, so I need to go
to
torch build torch.
Hey, I'm gonna comment that out.
Are you building a Docker container?
All right, I got to sleep. So, uh I will
say because there are some folks on
YouTube. Um for folks watching or dev
tomorrow, cleaning some stuff up, docs,
whatever we need to do, getting this
release ready. Uh it's all open source.
Find
apuffer.ai. Want to help me out for
free? Start the GitHub. And uh if you
want to get involved with dev, you know,
most of these things are written by
contributors who came in with zero RL
experience. It's a great way to get into
AI, great way to contribute science,
it's a great way to learn stuff. Join
Discord for that and otherwise follow me
on X for